guys i'm lagging a little bit but the game isn't so honestly i don't care so much
we all knew this would happen
oh my gosh you guys my voice is so dead from this weekend i'm so sorry i was i was screaming my head off so i'm sorry my voice is my voice is a little dead um welcome oh my gosh well
i can't i
can't Oh my gosh, that's where our stuff is gonna be.
Oh my god, it looks so pretty.
Oh no.
I had to change some settings.
I already changed things that hopefully would reduce lag and everything.
If I'm lagging, it's okay.
Oh, thank you for that, guys.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, welcome.
Welcome.
Oh gosh.
I can't believe we're actually here I can't believe we're actually here And I'm like completely Right now I'm completely I mean I'm already Super Metal Gear brand All the time Oh my god You can't show me that guy In your profile picture Meow Why are people changing their profile picture To You can't do this to me.
Why are you guys doing this?
Why?
Stop!
Sorry, oh my gosh.
My voice is so dead.
Oh my god.
Too late.
Did you guys play this?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna cry.
I'm already crying.
Pretty good.
I just came back from a convention, MGSCon, where I was a digital host.
And I had so much fun.
And everybody was so nice.
And...
Wow.
Look, there's so many of you guys.
Wait, what are you talking about?
What is yours?
I can't even tell.
And, um...
So, I'm already so, like, hyped on Metal Gear stuff.
And...
Um...
Oh, my gosh.
And now we're playing...
Oh my god.
Even though...
Even though it's not a new story.
It's still so exciting.
And, um...
For anybody...
I'll just say this right now.
now because I know many people have many opinions um if you want to be you know if you want to state your negative opinion this is not the place to do so so um you know there there's lots of other avenues please don't use my chat nor my comment section you will be either banned or timed out so
So, please, please.
We're just here to have fun, okay?
Reddit exists for that.
Exactly.
Game has been getting super positive reviews.
I've played it twice now.
I played it at TGS last year, and now I'm playing it...
Or I played it a couple weeks ago in New York.
now but the first time I played it I'm pretty sure it was Xbox set last time it was PS5 and now I'm playing it PC I honestly would have played it on my PS5 but I was a dummy dumb and I got the super deluxe edition to play early on Steam and I didn't think about it I didn't think about it so I was like oh shoot.
I know I'm going to be all laggy and everything, but it's okay.
It's okay.
My negative opinion is that Ocelot should strip.
So true.
Why are you playing with a controller?
Of course I am.
Of course.
That's actually why.
At the pop-up in New York, they had like all the different systems.
Most people actually picked PC, which I thought was pretty interesting.
but I didn't remember seeing if the PC version had a controller with it.
And I knew I would be playing with controller because it just feels natural.
It just feels natural, so I was like, I'll just pick the PS5 version.
And I know some people were saying that the PS5 version has frame rate issues, but I didn't experience anything when I played it.
I don't know.
I don't really care about that kind of stuff.
I'm just here for Metal Gear.
I'm just here for Metal Gear to have a good time.
So let's not bring that up.
You know, if I have issues, I like I'm having issues kind of right now, but that is to be expected with being a digital anime woman.
This happens every time.
This is this is not on the game.
It's I'm too, I'm too, I'm too beefy.
So, yeah.
Let's just, uh, let's just have fun with it, okay?
Again, please don't get, I don't want to see it.
If you have anything negative to say, go scream it into the sea.
Go outside or yell it into your pillow.
Yeah!
This is guy in my profile picture.
You guys with your profile pictures are so funny.
If I don't have a seat?
Yeah, scream it into your pillow.
I want to play as much as I can today.
I might just get really into it.
And play the whole thing.
Who knows?
But...
Yeah!
I'm excited.
Wait, you can hear it.
Okay, good.
I turned the music.
I want to play Snake versus...
Did you guys know Astrobotus in this game?
Look at him hugging him so tightly.
Did you guys know Astrobotus in this game too?
This game was...
It's perfect.
Yeah, he's in the people.
Snake V Monkey.
And I guess you have to beat the game to unlock the...
The, what's it?
Fox Hunt?
What's under Extras?
So, Secret Theater, I think is kind of funny.
How they do it.
You can either collect...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the music.
Sorry.
I think of us a lot.
You can either collect them in the game or it's kind of nice.
They all unlock at the end.
That's our camel collection.
cute look at this i already have these because i got the dlc oh oh oh oh no oh no oh this bag has jiggle physics oh god oh nothing else with jiggle physics come on konami oh i also want to say i'm obviously not sponsored this stream oh i will everything will be my my my own thoughts and opinions He's so cool,
I know.
No,
no, no.
I'm not ready for that one.
This is so funny.
I wore this one when I played.
I wore this one when I played in New York.
It's so good without the hat.
I don't know.
It's just so, like, wide around his neck.
He's an absolute unit.
Look at this man.
Holy cow.
I need to see his ass better.
We'll see it when he's crawling around, maybe.
I'm excited, too, to see, like, the scarring system.
I feel like we haven't really seen much of that.
It's shown off at all.
Wow, he's really...
Wow, the vids!
Whoa!
Wait, there's a zoom in.
Oh, oh, oh, no, I'm not.
Can't do that.
Okay, and then we can just make him go.
Holy cow.
What is his face?
Ew.
I... Ew.
And for anybody wondering, yes, if you do spin him around in the viewfinder, he does throw up.
That was the first thing I checked.
Ew.
I hate this.
I feel like his eyes really just throw it off.
He's a trophy now.
Trophy.
Trophy wife.
So yeah, we'll get the other ones.
What's this one?
Mysterious.
Oh wait, do I have to download them?
Oh no, I guess that means DLC, right?
Oh, I can't look at the token.
I don't think I'm ready for it.
I can't look at the tuxedo.
I am the owner of the one and only 24 karat.
Wait, actually.
Wait.
Oh, they say what each one does.
That's kind of nice.
Significantly lowers the camo index while boosting movement speed.
Naked.
Naked with belts of ammo.
That's all it is.
It's just naked.
Naked with camouflage.
Makes any food taste great while also boosting movement speed.
when crawling and increasing stamina consumption.
What?
Move with finesse.
Hold on.
I'm blocking my view.
Move with finesse.
Silencing.
Oh gosh.
I can't.
With him with glasses on.
I think I might I think I might go to heaven.
Okay, hold on.
Move with finesse.
Silencing your footsteps and doubling your natural life recovery rate.
If the jacket gets dirty, the effects are lost.
Shut up.
That's too good.
That's so funny.
No way.
I wonder if this one is like, yeah, greatly reduces all damage.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Boost natural life recovery, but decreases movement speed.
So it's kind of the same.
Yeah, yeah, eliminates the sound of footsteps.
Oh, yeah.
So these are sneak, but we get the sneaking suit later.
the the wow actually this one is quite big on his neck too no i guess it's not so tight as i expected it should be tighter tighter my oshi has literacy issues what are you talking about no i don't and there's so many here holy cow there's so many face Oh,
wait.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Wait, we also have the masks, though.
Maybe they're not under face.
Okay, I think sunglasses I'm okay with.
Wait.
Why is it?
It's showing up.
It's broken.
No preview for them?
Oh, and then you get a, oh no, wow, snake.
Whatever, there's so many different kinds of snakes.
Land-based animal, water-based animal.
Mushroom.
Other.
Well, that must be, like, ramen and stuff.
Oh, there's a, oh, so guys, there's a camera.
There's a photo mode in this game.
I'm, I'm so excited.
Okay, okay, we're done looking at extras.
I'm ready to play the game.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh my gosh, okay.
This one I was excited about because I rushed through everything at the playthrough just to get to the cutscene with Ocelot when I played in New York.
So I actually didn't see which one, what these offer.
So I'm playing MGS for the first time.
Gives you a mummy uniform.
This one gives you a DPM.
What's DPM uniform?
This one gives you, I like MGS2, gives you Desert Tiger uniform.
Oh, the art.
I like MGS3 gives you the Fleck Tarn uniform.
And this is so exciting!
Now we can, oh my gosh, we actually have, I like MGS4 and Onwards.
Like, that's so exciting.
I like MGS4, it gives you face green and face brown.
I like Peace Walker.
Oh my gosh, this is so perfect.
Peace Walker gives you the banana uniform.
That's so perfect.
No poops, yeah.
Four, I mean, stop, that four.
Five gives you national flags.
Face.
Face, Nash, not uniform.
And then I like everything.
Gives you grenade uniform.
I'm assuming then we don't have I'm assuming then that the Rykov mask is automatically given to us?
That was some fancy freaking.
Where's the I like patchy slide option?
So I guess I'm assuming...
We all know that the mask is still there, so I guess I guess they just give it to you automatically.
though what's the grenade uniform what does it do they don't tell you what they do i like ghost babble
oh the old snake
unlimited grenades wait actually infinite grenades are you guys are you guys pulling my leg that would be so crazy I wonder what the banana uniform does too does it make you smell like banana it's kind of nice yes no infinite ammo mmm make you smell like bananas and all the guards smell you and are just like mmm yummy what's a fleck torn uniform oh I'm gonna Google it.
Guess what it means.
Flectar.
Sorry, my big old head is blocking exactly where it says the additional equipment.
Ah, okay, it's just like, oh, it's just camo.
It's just a camo.
I like Revengeance all BGM changes to butt Brock Bradley.
Let's go with everything, man.
Because it's true.
Minus this one.
But, no, no, that's...
I'm kidding.
I'm being harsh.
I also like that all of these pictures are snake except two.
They could have easily squeezed snake's face in there.
But nah, they were like, Raiden gets his time.
Raiden gets his time.
Okay, I like everything.
I want to play with modern action game controls.
Move and fire weapons simultaneously.
Now here's where I'm a little...
I don't know what to do.
Do I want to play...
I did try Legacy style at the New York playthrough.
But I'm also like, do I want to try the game through a new perspective?
Though I wonder if it'll become kind of like a twin snakes.
Where some bosses are like...
I think that was some people's concerns too.
If it would become a little like...
Too easy!
New style?
I think so too.
I'm thinking, you know...
Well, I'm gonna put the filter on though, just to let you guys know.
I'm gonna put the...
You can change it whenever you want.
Okay, good to know.
I think a new style for a new, fresh playthrough, right?
What's button layout?
Oh!
Okay.
Oh gosh, it's all gonna be so different.
Not so different.
Stalking?
Oh yeah, bye bye.
Okay, we'll get to it.
We'll get to it.
Difficulty.
I'm here for a good time.
So we're going on normal.
Like, you don't even have European Extreme unlocked.
Holy cow.
Highest achieved title is... wait, this one...
Foxhound, yeah, Fox.
Is he smoke in there?
Snake starts with the easy gun.
A silent tranquilizer gun with infinite ammo!
Oh my gosh.
Wow, infinite ammo.
Funny.
Okay.
That one's easy.
Let's see.
View all tips.
Important tips.
pop-up tips display only tips that do not interrupt gameplay hide tips
easy baby mode what is hero extreme that's one where like if you get any if you get if you get caught at all you die no
I feel like I'm gonna want reminders on how to different controls, so I'm gonna do view all tips.
Correct, yeah.
So permadeath, no, it, yeah, it's really get spotted.
You have to, it's ultimate stealth mode.
If you're spotted, it's immediate game over.
Oh, war has changed, is the?
After the end of World War II, the world was split into two, east and west.
This marked the beginning of the era
Based on Metal Gear Solid 3.
Wait, we're gonna see the new intro then.
Josh, Keaton!
Oh, Selai!
Oh, gosh.
I've met so many of these people this past weekend.
It's crazy.
So many!
Fly over Pakistan.
Altitude 30,000 feet.
Approaching Soviet airspace.
20 minutes to drop off.
Carrying internal depressurization.
Equipment check.
Paramedic looks so cute.
Oh my god!
She's beautiful!
God!
She looks so pretty.
She could be in Final Fantasy.
Gosh!
There he is, guys.
He's in the credits.
Everyone can shut up.
There's Tomokazu Fukushima.
He's in the credits.
You can all shut up.
Put out that cigar.
Connecting oxygen hose to interior connector.
Put on your mask.
Oh my gosh.
Thanks, Johnny's combat.
Does this panty waste know what he's doing?
Approaching release point.
minutes to drop off hey are you deaf he said put out the cigar and put on your mask sorry zero I had a crush on paramedic before but wow she's really beautiful deep pressurization complete checking oxygen supply six minutes to drop off opening rear hatch I also skipped all the cutscenes when I last played in New York.
So, this is all kind of new to me, too.
Yeah, we were timed.
And I also just wanted to see us a lot.
God, it looks so...
So good!
Holy hell.
It was first Halo jump!
Gosh, and this is not Ultra graphics either.
I did change it to high.
Your
wings and fly!
Yeah, this is high graphics.
Not Ultra.
Oh my god.
Did you guys see the intro video that we made for MGSCon?
Look at that.
Jack, I've got some important news.
The head of the CIA has finally given us the green light for the virtuous mission.
Virtual mission?
Virtual mission.
No, the virtuous mission.
The future of our fogs.
unit depends on it if it succeeds will be officially organized into a unit virtuous mission sounds like some kind of initiation ritual don't get cocky this isn't a training oh no I can't shut up I'm so sorry well about two years ago a certain Soviet scientist requested asylum in the West through one of our moles scenes will be changed his name is Nikolai Stepanovich Soviet Sokolov.
He's head of the OKB754 designer.
The real footage.
Because I think they had to change some, right?
And the East's foremost expert on weapons development.
Sokolov.
Wait, are we gonna see Sokolov's ugly wife?
Wait, in...
In...
In high-deaf, I need to see her.
Oh my gosh, I can't...
It's so...
The Earth was blue, but there was no God.
Well spoken.
Oh my god, it's so grainy.
It's even worse.
Sokolov is said to be the man most responsible for the multi-engine cluster used.
But they get David Hader back.
Yeah, this is all actually the original cast because it's the original lines.
Sokolov left rocket development to become the head of the newly established design bureau.
And Konami has been really great about working with David Hader and the cast to kind of be promoting the game and everything.
It seems she's become afraid of his own creations.
afraid call it a crisis of conscience and for that he left his country and went over the fence not exactly I thought these pictures would look better in this version we used a mole to get the family out first yeah it's original audio circle off over the Berlin Wall shortly afterwards I imagine only re I was the one who because they I think they said that they re-recorded some things and Imagine that's only,
like, control stuff.
But the story is all the same, same, same.
But the whole ordeal had left him exhausted.
And we checked him into a hospital in West Berlin.
It took him two weeks and more than 600 miles to get from the research facility in the Soviet Union to Berlin.
He was in no condition to say anything coherent.
I can't even tell what it is.
Real people!
October 16th, 2016.
too.
President Kennedy received word that the Soviets were in the process of deploying intermediate-range ballistic missiles in Cuba.
Old footage went in 4K.
The same time he announced a naval blockade to prevent further missile shipments from being in Cuba.
I can't even read anything.
But the Soviets didn't back down.
I'm blind.
Instead, placing their armed forces on secondary alert.
Soviet transport ships carrying missiles continued on course if you squint.
Not even.
The U.S.
and Soviet forces went on alert for an all-out nuclear war frantic negotiations were conducted through the u.n's emergency security kennedy and unofficial jfk to end the hair trigger stand on finally you got the real jfk to act out the scene yeah yeah and so the world avoided a nuclear holocaust but in order to get the so can anyone read lips we had to make a deal you you need the one where the u.s agreed to remove its irbms from turkey no the jupiter irbm deployed in Turkey were obsolete and we were gonna get rid of them anyway they had no strategic value whatsoever to either the US or the Russians the Turkey deal was a roof saying I love a cover story that was fed to the other intelligence agencies around the world so what did the Russians really want so I want to see Sokolov's ugly wife the Soviets pulled out of Cuba just to get their hands on Sokolov that's right what the hell was he working on At the time we had no idea.
We were running out of time.
It was either give up Sokolov or risk full-scale nuclear war.
In the end, we had no choice.
President Kennedy gave him...
Stop calling her ugly.
Okay, but once you see her, you all understand.
She looks like a beast.
Agents on the eastern side.
Oh my god, he's tripping.
I can't tell what's going on in this picture at all.
He's fallen and he can't get up.
We received some new information from one of our moles.
Okay, what is that?
What is that?
He was taken back to the research facility.
Broccoli?
Continue working on the weapon in question.
Oh, I think that's the Shagohan.
I can't.
What's more, it's on the verge of completion.
So what kind of weapon is it?
It's the Shagohan.
Something to do with space rockets?
No.
Okay, maybe they should have, like, turned off the grain just a tiny bit for this.
I guess you're right.
We don't know the details.
but it appears to be a new kind of nuclear device for half a year now the soviets have been conducting frequent nuclear tests at semi-palatinsk it's not a spoiler we know it's a weapon we're talking about a secret weapon so big that khrushchev is ready to pull out of cuba to get it back is sokolov still in a facility how do we know it's old without the grain no according to our intelligence he's in selino yarsk about three miles to the west that's known as the virgin cliffs
nice name for a virtuous mission they moved him there just recently why apparently they're conducting a field test of the weapon it's our best chance to get him back this mission would never have been possible in the research facility this is our last chance sokolov must have known that too why did he say that i'm gonna make snake really muddy i'm
gonna make him look like he's
Go, stay cool!
Oh, no, I'm lagging.
So pretty.
Listen up, Jack.
Your mission is to infiltrate City, New York, in the Soviet mountains.
You're sure you saved your Sokolov, but bring it back to the west.
Oh my gosh, wait, that means all the hidden RVs are there!
Oh, yeah!
If we don't get Sokolov back before that weapon is complete, we'll be facing a major crash.
The clock is ticking.
I saw
the logo Once we've confirmed the rescue of Sokolov Stand by at the recovery point A recovery balloon will be dropped at that point Rocklead Helium will be pumped into the balloon to inflate it The process takes about 20 minutes Yummy Once it's complete Gunship's arm will latch onto the balloon and pull it up The Fulton's surface to air recovery system I'm familiar with the Oh Fulton Take it easy It's been combat proven Apparently medic is so pretty do you think so glove is i wish we saw more of her 3d model you know shock will be less than during a parachute you see it here and then at the very end of the game and that's it why was that guy looking at her like that walmart kai is a hero miller over there she's equipped with two six barrel 20 millimeter vulcan cannons as well as two 40 millimeter machine guns sounds like she could hold her own against a battalion of tanks she's so pretty
all goes well it shouldn't take more than a few hours home in time for dinner but if anything goes wrong you'll be eating dinner breakfast and all the rest of your meals in the jungle they all are guys i've talked about this with friends before but like metal gear is just completely full of attractive people it's literally made for everybody anybody and anybody in this game is attractive they're all so handsome and beautiful i can't get over it i oh i did turn off motion blur so just letting the guys know oh my stuff my stuff
the pose the pose
I clapped when I saw it
But I guess because you don't You can't get like the The Rykov Ryden version Just kind of sad
Ah Ah
Okay, so I was holding my breath.
Do you copy?
You're already in enemy territory, and somebody might be listening in.
He's getting real close.
We'll be using codenames to refer to each other.
Your codename for this mission will be naked snake.
I'll be referring to you as snake.
It's kind of like a...
Like, it's really wide over here.
Snake.
You don't like snakes?
What do you mean?
Oh, he got me!
He looks so good.
I'm glad to hear that.
order one in a restaurant but be careful you might not have a choice what about you major what should i call you let's see i'll be i'll be tom i like how though it says major zero literally right here oh it updated i've never seen that you must leave no trace of your presence is that clear it updated infiltration is the fox unit wow interesting that was cool wait i've never seen that completely naked just as your name implies isn't that a song now you'll see why you asked me if i like snakes i suppose calling me snake was your idea of a joke town no you got some drool there i'm sorry i can't stop i can't stop myself exactly am i supposed to feed myself you've been issued a knife and a tranquilizer gun use them to hunt for food you'll also find some medical supplies in your backpack yeah about the backpack i lost it in a tree on the way down i see well you better go back and get it oh my gosh you know where it is yes no problem i can see it from here it's oh my gosh he's even looking at
everything oh to climb a tree stand in front of a tree that's covered in ivy and press the action button a i'll be monitoring your progress over the radio we can't risk violating soviet airspace but
40.85 i'll give you a call if i need to talk to you you need to talk to me use the send function okay snake go get your backpack okay hopefully i don't start lagging like crazy oh i'm okay all right you guys were here oh wait man since i'm in new style oh no wait i can move around i can see everything oh no
sorry oh gosh i found that legacy style almost mimicked um like the original original free cam oh free cam oh free cam oh free cam oh and oh my gosh oh no no no Oh, no, no, no, no, I can get the prettiest pictures of this man.
Oh, no, no.
Hide characters.
Hide all butt.
Wait, I'm sorry.
Oh, sorry.
If I just clicked out of the game, it's in full screen.
So hide all butt snake.
I'm actually going to scoot over a bit because I imagine my stuff will be on the side.
There we go.
No!
Sorry.
yeah break it back no oh logo type oh cute filter
retro brown legacy wait legacy i feel like action movie looks more like the original than legacy does
is a good like this is a good pissy filter wait bring back snake there
green it's kind of dark though it's kind of dark
darkness oh goodbye snake depth of field oh my gosh i'm gonna get all pictures oh no no no no okay yes exit photo mode use photo mode for the first time paparazzo snake this is what it's called also you see that the the the kero tan and the gako in the corner good to know good to know and then how do i Okay,
so this is the survival viewer.
So this is how I changed my camouflage.
And then this is the pause.
Okay.
Okay, got it.
Got it.
Ribbit.
How do I...
Okay.
So this is crouch walk.
Sorry, new controls.
I want to see an animal.
I want to see a little critter.
Oh, it's so pretty.
Stand tall.
Ribbit.
I hear one.
I hear a frog.
Ribbit.
Okay, whatever.
And then, okay.
This, okay.
And then if I run, GoPro, okay, Elder Crawl.
Okay, so yeah.
How do I like...
There we go.
Okay.
Oh no!
I got him all dirty!
Oh my god!
Oh, but that, not always.
Stop!
That's so good!
What?
Oh my gosh!
What is this?
What does X do?
Okay, I don't know.
Sorry, I'm like just messing around right now.
He's all dirty!
Remember the basics of CQC.
Yes, boss.
There's our stuff.
Oh, it's iconic.
Wait, I want a picture.
I want a picture.
One moment.
Please.
Snake looks a little...
There's nothing going on behind those eyes at all.
There's nothing going...
Wait, I kind of want it from the back.
Wait, turn around, snakes.
I want him, like, looking at it.
I'm looking a little less stupid.
Let's see.
Wait.
He's not looking at it at all.
Snakes!
I won't do this all the time, by the way.
Don't worry.
Oh, and...
Oh, cool.
Whoa.
Wait, where am I?
Backshot.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll just filter.
It's so iconic.
I have to take a picture.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Okay, how do I take it?
Cheese!
How do I take the picture?
Um, booty shot, booty shot.
Oh, I take the picture.
F12.
Oh!
I hope my cursor didn't get in there.
Uh-oh.
Am I in the game still?
Okay.
Okie dokie, okie dokie.
Climbing the ladder.
Not the tree.
Alt F4 True Hey Over Over I like how the movie borders Show up when it's time for a cutscene I see you've retrieved your backpack, Snake To equip a weapon It's necessary to take it out of your backpack in the survival viewer the letterbox from the backpack your available weapons will be displayed in a list on the screen from that list choose the weapon you want to equip and press the enter button for other equipped items just do the same thing from item got it use the survival viewer backpack yep that's right survival is fundamental to this mission after you've been out in the field for a while your stamina will start to drop if your stamina gets too low it'll affect you won't be able to shoot accurately for example and your wounds will heal as smoothly keep an eye on your stamina so you don't run out to recover lost stamina you can hunt for local flora and fauna yeah you can use either your tranquilizer gun or your knife to hunt my only weapon is a mark 22 hush puppy tranquilizer gun
that's right it's been fitted with its own suppressor however the suppressor will deteriorate every time I'm chewing gum I'm chewing oatmeal it's my will be gone so don't get too trigger happy with it the suppressor's durability is shown in the icon any weapons and equipment beyond what you're carrying now you'll have to find as you go i have to find my own weapons and equipment whose crazy idea was this anyway solo covert actions are standard fox operating procedure you can't leave any traces of your presence no weapons equipment footprints sweat or bodily wastes the same goes for bullets and too.
Your presence in enemy territory is already a violation of international conventions of warfare.
There aren't supposed to be any American soldiers in Russia.
It could spark an international incident.
You can't let anyone see you.
You can't let the enemy know you're there.
This is a stealth mission.
You're a ghost snake in every sense of the word.
There will be no rescue if you're captured.
The military and US government will deny any involvement in your action.
Then I'll just have to take care of myself, huh?
I'm afraid so I've been given a fake death pill for that purpose SIS guidelines stipulate that soldiers on covert ops like this one for the issue of potassium cyanide capsule just like me for real how generous of you use it if you're taken prisoner by the enemy oh yeah state of false death for a short time fooling them into thinking that I'm really dead so how do I come back to life just take the revival pill you mean that they put in my tooth before the mission that's the one but be careful if you remain in a state of false death for too long nothing will be able to bring you back whoa it was freaking i'll keep it in mind become a real death you said this was a solo mission right right i guess that means i can't count on any time paradox correct the mission rests entirely in your hands a real one-man army relax there's a support team ready to back you up over the radio pill eater Listen to you.
This time, survival is of utmost importance.
The first member of the support team will be in charge of monitoring your physical condition.
Traces almost as if he's...
As well as recording your mission data.
He's a member of Fox as well, and she's here on the gunship with me.
Hello, Snake.
I'm Paramedic.
Nice to meet you.
Oh.
Paramedic.
My God.
As in a medic who comes in by parachute.
Aren't you going to tell me your name?
Paramedic's voice actress.
Are you going to tell me yours, Mr. Snake?
my name is the sweetest it's john doe and they call you jack for short you're a regular captain nemo she was so a name means nothing on the battlefield after a week no one has a name i'll talk about it what's your name i know this is like the longest cut scene but very funny i wasn't joking but i'll tell you my name only if you manage to make it back alive my frequency is 145.73 she's also in charge of recording your mission data whenever you want to save send a message over the save frequency 140.96 so saving lets me record my mission data that's right it also records the state of your health good to know there's one more person I want to introduce I was trying to look at her let me see the lady of snakes you remember the boss don't you a legendary soldier and your mentor actually it was the boss that got the DCI's authorization in the first place she's going to be boss is she also helped me plan this mission she and i were at sas together jack is that you how many years has it been
boss that's right it's me oh talk to me let me hear your voice it's been five years 72 days and 18 hours you've lost weight you can tell just by the sound of my voice of course I can I know all about you really well I don't know anything about you what's that supposed to mean why'd you disappear on me all of a sudden I was on a top secret mission you didn't need me anymore but there were still so many things I wanted you to teach me I don't know what it is about the boss I taught you everything you needed to know about fighting but her voice is so I thought makes me so emotional the rest you needed to learn on the whale and sponge.
Techniques sure, but what about how to think like a soldier?
How to think like a soldier?
I can't teach you that.
A soldier needs to be strong in spirit, body, and technique, and the only thing you can learn from someone else is technique.
In fact, technique doesn't even matter what's most important is spirit.
Spirit and body are like two sides of a single coin.
They're the same thing.
I can't teach you how to think.
You'll just have to figure it out for yourself.
Listen to me, Jack.
Just because soldiers are on the same side right now, doesn't mean they always will be.
Having personal feelings about your comrades is one of the worst sins you can commit.
Politics determine who you face on the battlefield.
And politics are a living thing.
They change along with the times.
Yesterday's good might be tomorrow's evil.
Is that why you abandoned me?
No, it had nothing to do with you.
I've I already told you, Jack, I was on a top-secret mission.
A soldier has to follow whatever orders he's given.
It's not his place to question why.
But you're looking for a reason to fight.
You're a natural-born fighter, but you're not quite a soldier.
A soldier is a political tool, nothing more.
That's doubly true if he's a career soldier.
Right and wrong have no place in his mission.
He has no enemies and no friends.
only the mission you follow the orders you're given that's what being watching this game oh my goodness I do whatever I have to to get the job you're in for such a ride I don't think about politics that's not the same thing sooner or later your conscience is going to bother you in the end you have to choose whether you're going to live as a soldier or just another man with a gun there's a saying in the Orient loyalty to the end do you know what it means being patient It means devoting yourself to your country.
I follow the president and the top brass.
I'm ready to die for them if necessary.
The president and the top brass won't be there forever.
Once their terms are up, others will take their place.
I follow the will of the leader, no matter who's in charge.
People aren't the ones who dictate the missions.
Then who does?
The times.
People's values change over time.
And so do the leaders of a country.
so there's no such thing as an enemy in absolute terms the enemies we fight are only enemies in relative terms constantly changing with the times as long as we have loyalty to the end there's no point in believing in anything even in those we love and that's the way a soldier supposed to think sounds like they put more of a filter on her voice with absolute certainty sounds like she's more like radio like you know all right but do me a favor it call me snake snake oh right your code name is snake it suits you well oh that's right the legendary unit that the boss put together during World War two was a snake the Cobra unit a group of heroes that brought the water I hear it now more on on zero a major time to backing you up you'll be fine isn't that right snake yeah yeah they added a radio filter to all yeah except snake oh and one more thing boss yes it's good to hear your voice again same here she's so pretty oh my god if either of us will make it out alive snake you are always best at
urban warfare and infiltrating buildings but this is the jungle survival is going to be key those cqc techniques i taught you are sure to come in handy cqc close quarters combat huh i've been in the green braids for the past few not to worry I'll be here to help you remember the basics after all this is your first actual survival mission I'll be supporting you over the radio where are you boss next to the major the boss is communicating with us by radio from a board of permit class submarine in the Arctic Ocean my frequency is 141.80 call me if you need my advice on battle techniques gotcha gotcha your mission is to retrieve Dr. Sokolov.
Okay.
Dr. Sokolov is being held in an abandoned factory located to the north of your current position.
I can't see that low location.
Avoid heavy combat and don't let anyone see you.
Don't forget that this is a stealth mission.
Okay.
Snake, try to remember some of the basics of CQC.
Oh, say the line.
Say the line, Snake.
Say the line!
Commencing virtuous mission now.
She said the line.
We're all saying lines.
Open survival viewer.
We got our camo.
You can wear camouflage to blend in with your environment.
Wait, where was he?
Where was the camo?
Oh, wait.
Wearing it allows you to use grenades.
It is.
Oh.
It is limitless grenade.
No, stinking way.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
where like the line is that it's a mask that is crazy like they actually were like yeah it's a mask you can actually see it like right there on his neck oh wow that's so good that's actually so good uh does ryden have blue eyes now i think about it i know snake does i guess it's good if I think riding does yeah so pretty convenient well this is not riding this is not riding everybody sorry this is not riding this is not riding yeah not riding oh gosh
so goofy can't
even look at it if I can't Oh, I kept it on!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
There we go.
Oh!
Let's see.
Um...
Cold.
Oh, you can't do CQC in the white talks.
Let's do the crocsuit.
It's so funny.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Big snike.
Wait, where's that guy just chilling out here?
Don't attack me, right?
Snake G.
Capture any animal alive.
Can I keep it?
Okay, wait.
How do I change?
Okay, here we go.
So like this.
All right, all right, all right, all right.
Okay, okay.
Like that.
Oh, I'm going to move over.
A tad slight.
Oh!
Sorry.
A tad slight more.
I'm going to make myself a little bit smaller.
Sorry.
you guys to see the UI as much as possible.
I'm being bogged by slow connection.
Hi, Barry!
Okay.
There we go.
Hi, Barry!
Barry, look at me.
Oh, he's huge!
Look at him!
He's ginormous!
He is the biggest guy I've ever seen in my life!
Afterlife!
Holy...
Okay, wait.
Oh, achieve a camo index of 90% or higher.
That's fun.
Wait, how do I...
How do I...
How do I attack?
How do I attack with it?
Oh my gosh, it's so pretty.
This game is so pretty.
Look at the details.
Again.
This is not...
Hello?
Oh, here we go.
Oh, I have to...
I have to, okay, okay.
This is not ultra quality.
This is just high quality.
Wait, you could hear the croc suit, like the rubber.
Do you hear it?
He's so, he's like squeaky.
No croc head?
We gotta, we gotta go get that.
What are you talking about?
You never start with the croc head.
You gotta go get it.
Okay, so radio.
Yes, I forgot this was a thing.
Wait.
Boss.
Oh, I'm in the croc suit.
Camouflage is an indispensable tool when you're sneaking through the jungle.
No!
To use camouflage, first press the survival viewer button to go to the survival viewer.
and press the enter button select a uniform to select battle fatigue and face to select face paint choose battle fatigues that match the surrounding environment oh my god he's got his little claw in there by selecting fatigues that blend in with the no way camouflage patterns that stand out in your surroundings will attract attention it's so funny um what's called paramedic I I see you've captured a giant anaconda.
The giant anaconda is believed to be the largest snake in the world in terms of...
I want him to give me a backscratch.
It's not poisonous, but its large size makes it extremely powerful.
They say it even with crocodiles.
Its only natural predator is man.
And snake.
I love this one.
So how does it taste?
I knew you were going to ask me that.
Glad I didn't disappoint you.
So...
Well, the guide says it tastes all right.
Good.
I'll have to try some.
Oh,
gosh.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, you can, like, quick save.
That's kind of fun.
There's, like, X to save.
Wait, if I do this.
Oh, wow, yeah, yeah.
Oh, so fast!
Xenophile!
Listen to paramedic talk about movies after you say it.
You haven't seen it?
Nope.
It's about this monster called Godzilla.
It looks just like us.
It's an enormous size in a nuclear test and goes on a rampage in Tokyo.
Movie talk, baby!
That Marshall Islands must be crawling with giant monsters right about now.
It's just make-believe.
Maybe that's why my pants have been so tight lately.
Snake, it's a movie, not a report out of Los Alamos.
I know.
So then what happened?
Why did he say that?
Godzilla is immune to all weapons and humanity has no way to stop the monster.
Dr. Sira-zawa developed a new type of weapon.
But meanwhile, Godzilla is getting closer and closer to Tokyo, obliterating everything in his path.
Why does it say that?
I recommend seeing the original Japanese one if you ever get the chance.
It's mostly mindless fun, but it's also got a serious anti-nuke message as well.
Where can I see the original?
You'll just have to go to Japan.
Really?
That's too bad.
might be able to see it in America too.
That's so cute.
It might even win awards all across the globe in 60 years.
Why is that?
2024 will be Godzilla's 70th birthday.
You think they're still going to be making Godzilla movies then?
Wait!
Of course.
Last year!
Everybody loves Godzilla.
You sure know a lot about movies.
I don't suppose you're the movie watching type, are you?
Not really.
How did you know?
Then I'll tell you everything I know.
When the going- New lion!
Movies can save your life.
Oh, I was going to say about that.
paramedic to look at things from a different perspective when you get in a jam that's so cool wait they updated it to say 2024 that's the spirit that's so stinking cute that is such a cute attention to detail that is actually so so stinking cute oh my gosh um i wanted to say about paramedic because she was at the voice actress for paramedic was at mgs con i believe her Sorry,
I'm bad with last name.
I'm bad with names, but it was her first ever convention ever ever and she was so, oh my gosh, she was so, she was like crying.
She was so grateful to, to be there.
Heather Haley, Haley, Haley, Haley?
Yeah.
She was so, so sweet.
She was so, so grateful and she loves paramedics.
She loves being paramedics.
She would just like say she was so excited.
She was just like I would watch old movies just like Paramedic and be like wow this movie is so much like Paramedic story and like she oh my gosh listening to her was infectious because she was so happy about the role.
It was so she yeah she pretty much was paramedic.
She even said she was like she was like it was so fun to have a role that was so similar to me and then she was just she was like obviously i'm not gonna go too much into what she said because it also is spoilers but she was like going off about like paramedic's lore and what paramedic goes on to do and future games and i was just so impressed i was so impressed that she like you know knew so much about the character she was so enthralled with the role It was such a good weekend.
It was such a good weekend.
MGSCon is taking a break next year.
But I think if you are interested in going and they do one the year after, you should definitely check it out.
Definitely, definitely.
Okay.
Here, I want to try something.
I might die.
Oh, hello.
I want to get real nice and dirty.
I want to get real nasty with it.
Holy cow.
I want to get nasty.
I'm ready to get disgusted.
Come on, Snake.
Come on.
Oh, gosh.
I might dive.
Oh, crawl, crawl, crawl.
Okay.
Wait, maybe this would be good.
Wait.
Oh, get up.
Oh.
Oh, we're covered in moss.
There it goes.
wait hold on let me let me take off our camo and stuff oh nasty wait okay so that just wait can i make rikov nasty
oh no please no
okay i know how the backpack works well moment, one moment.
This is for science.
Wait, what am I doing?
All up in there.
Wait, oh gosh, oh gosh, don't die.
Oh gosh, keep crawling.
Okay, sorry, I knew, I had a feeling I was gonna die.
I can't wait a second.
Okay, We got this.
We got this.
Okay.
Alright.
Snake is dead.
Okay, turn around.
Oh,
he's filthy!
Oh, he's disgusting!
Ew!
Okay, I'm done.
I'm good.
I'm calm.
I'm cool.
I'm collected.
I'm calm.
I'm cool.
I'm collected.
Okay.
Oh, the roll.
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, hold on.
Oh.
Get out of there.
Does it work better?
Nah.
We're still nasty.
Still same nast.
about same same amounts probably i do know something um i forgot to be looking for kettotines and gakos but i do oh yeah right uh just okay hold on i'm trying to get used to the oh there's a quick change shut up that's wait that's up okay that's so handy okay and then okay This is this one.
That's nice.
Oh, jeez.
Come here.
There is a Gakko right here.
I saw him before.
Ugly duckling attack a Gakko for the first time.
I've been forgetting to search for the kerotano.
Gakko.
Excuse me.
It's a duck now.
There's both.
And it's always been a duck.
Gakko has always been an addition.
Oh!
No, she's...
My babe.
Get up.
And also, you guys, I don't know if you noticed, but there's crouch walking, which is huge.
Yeah, Kero-Tan, you can see here in the bottom right.
You can see Kero-Tan and Gakko.
Oh, and it shows you if you got the guy in that area.
Wait, that's so nice.
Okay, okay.
Gakko is probably going to be so much easier to find than Kero-Tan.
Kep-Tan, I imagine, will be kind of difficult, no?
Okay.
Oh!
Prince Charming, attack Akero time for the first time.
Wait, he's circling, it's so cute.
Wait, is he the piggy bank?
Oh, he is!
Chibi Minto with the bandana is super cute.
Thank you.
They spin!
It's so cute!
Alright, let's go attack some men.
Quero, quero, quero, quero.
You already missed 20.
Oh no, wait, I forgot to change.
I almost shook my controller.
Like, uh...
You know how in four you can shake the controller to turn off the camo?
Major, I've spotted two enemy soldiers.
They're probably KGB troops sent to guard Sokolov.
AK-47s and grenades.
Is this the beehive scene?
No.
Next area.
Don't worry.
Snake, your presence in Soviet territory is already a violation of international law.
We can't let the Kremlin find out that the CIA and the American government are involved.
Contact with the enemy is strictly prohibited.
Don't engage them in battle either.
This is a stealth mission.
Okay.
The major is right.
The point of this mission is to sneak through the jungle without being seen.
I just remembered if I killed the bird.
bunch of guys, the part.
Oh, oh my gosh, the part, I'm so excited.
Change your camouflage by selecting camouflage from the survival viewer.
I just remembered.
The uniform option lets you pick your uniform.
I'm so excited for spooky.
Oh my god, I'm so excited for spooky.
It's gonna, oh my gosh, what it's gonna look like.
Oh my god, I'm so excited.
Don't forget that anything that moves will stand out in the jungle.
If you just stand up and run around like an idiot, you're bound to be But if you crawl instead, you should be able to sneak by without being noticed.
I'm a gator.
You can see how effective your camouflage is by looking at the camo index.
The camo index shows how well your camouflage blends in with the surrounding area.
The higher the value, the harder you are to spot and vice versa.
The key is to make yourself one with nature.
Where is he here?
I don't see him.
In that little clip, I don't see him at all.
I like the, I actually really like the, what's it called, music though.
Oh,
okay, there we go.
Oops.
He's fine.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, my controller.
My bad.
The caution music, that's what I'm saying.
My camel's not really great right now, but I'm an alligator, so I don't...
Oops.
Oh, don't call anybody, please.
Oh, gosh.
There he goes.
Oh, you can see the...
Oh, wow.
Sorry, I'm, like, just looking at it.
You can see, like, the drop-off.
That's kind of crazy.
Trank has bullet drop.
Yeah, you can see it.
Wait, that's so nice.
Wait, that's cool.
I didn't know that.
Oh, wait, I want to drag him.
Oops.
Wait.
press up but I can't change my camo so I guess it's only maybe when you're not in caught okay we're test we're testing everything you guys we're testing it all right now
hold up let's try oh shoot no you didn't oh shit just kidding oh i kind of like the alert That thing too, that's nice.
There you go.
Bang, bang, bang, bang.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
Do I have to be...
Oh, oops.
Freeze!
Ah!
We're already starting.
This is so good.
Oh!
That feels good.
Wait, that feels so good.
We're fine.
Everything's cool.
And calm and collected.
Nice hold up.
I pressed the wrong button.
It feels so smooth.
Wait, do I have to hold X?
Ah, okay, here we go, okay.
It's quite nice.
Oh, okay, I reload it.
Okay, that's to reload.
Got it.
Hello.
Kick him awake.
I wonder if any of them have a secret theater.
How do I kick them?
Something's never changed.
Yeah, the CQC is definitely closer to five.
Definitely for sure.
Look at, you can see the track in the middle of it.
That's crazy.
That's so funny.
Okay.
I see
my suppressor running out.
Scaring me.
All right.
Let's go get...
Let's go get Sokolov.
Oh, wait.
No, sorry.
We have one more scene.
Oh, my gosh.
The bridge.
I'm stupid.
Hit CQC three times.
Oh, here it is!
Here it is!
Oh,
this is a little shit-eating grin.
Should I wait for the other guys to come?
Hmm.
Evil thoughts.
Since there's three of them.
I wonder if they'll all run away together.
Use bees to harass an enemy.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my gosh.
The drop off is kind of crazy.
The drop off is crazy.
Here they go!
Not the bees!
I'm gonna run out of bullets.
Oh, I suck.
Holy hell.
Like, here?
Okay, I give up.
I suck, you guys.
Okay, I also really suck at this bridge.
Just fair warning to you all.
I'm really bad at this bridge.
Hello?
Why can't I get him?
There we go.
Jeez.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna be fine.
Wait, am I actually gonna be fine?
I fell off this freaking thing like 10 times last time I played.
Are you kidding me?
I did it first try.
Keep going, Snake.
I really did fall off so many times last time.
Ow!
No, I'm even in New York.
Wait, no, go up.
I'm doing pull-ups again.
Climb.
There we go.
What is this, too?
go snake yeah in new york i fell off that thing like 50 times like crazy
can i train my grip just like in two pull up montage
it's so easy to see him kettotan is so difficult
um everybody we're screwed
how did they not see me dummies yeah i did take too long
it's okay we're trying out oh come on shake come on give me
okay let's just go To Sokolov, I zoomed through all of this before when I played in New York.
So I'm honestly just getting my fill of it now.
It did sound like the suppressor broke, but it showed it there, so I don't think so.
No gako.
It's okay.
I'm not trying to get all of them.
Major, I've reached the abandoned factory where Sokolov is supposedly being held.
This place is a dump.
let's place it with a jump you can crouch walk now I can't see Sokolov from here just like in MGS 3 3d there are sentries posted around the perimeter look at him it's a man your objective Sokolov is inside the factory they should be holding him in a room in the northeast section northeast section got it be careful your mission is to bring Sokolov back alive security is pretty tight and blind I don't know how they didn't see me not approach Sokolov while in the alert phase right I got I got only a lot you mean there's more not my peace worker shirt no when you get to Sokolov I want you to tell him something from me and that is sorry for being so late is that all yes understood beginning my approach to the target.
I'm making a mess of myself.
I'm making an absolute mess of myself.
That explains, oh.
That explains though, because when I was playing this, when I was playing this, I was, the drop off I mean, I was like kind of oops.
Oopsie.
Nope, nope, nope, nope.
Ouch.
There we go.
I was, like, struggling with some of the shots.
Actually, I still am.
Nothing has changed.
Like, I can't get the...
Maybe there's still drop-off, but you can't see it.
Okay.
I have five suppressors.
Now I look at it.
I think we're okay.
Gotta get used to that drop- I know.
My goodness.
That's gonna take me a second.
Okay.
But it's kind of nice that they show you.
I kind of, I like that still, but.
And what we're going to do here is we're going to equip our MD.
Maybe?
Motion detector.
Let's see.
We're on normal mode, normal, normal.
That's my camo.
Oh, okay.
I'm not used to the camo being in the bottom middle still.
I keep pressing up to change the quick camo change, but it's not working anymore.
I don't know what...
Oh, wrong button.
Sorry.
I don't know what I did.
Oh, I got leaves on me.
I also keep accidentally pressing B because it's circle, you know, in Japan.
So I'm having to redo all of this even still.
It does feel...
It's very familiar and feels like a new experience all at the same time.
Try holding it.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Oh, it's like...
Why... Wait, they're like quick change, but like...
Why this combo?
Why?
Interesting.
Okay.
I know there's a guy that goes up there, no?
Ugh.
I know where he is.
Sokolov.
Maybe I can get this guy.
A little aim, a little up.
Oh, shoot.
Don't call.
Don't...
Ow!
Shucks.
I cleared this part so easy before, though.
Down.
That was pretty good.
Oh, and game!
Christ is avoided.
I need to get used to this shot.
I need to.
I'm not very good at it.
Oh no.
Everybody, I apologize for the ghost that I am about to become.
I apologize.
Okay.
We still have another cutscene, though, before it.
And we still have this cutscene before.
Before.
Okay, we're fine.
Oh, wait.
What?
My ass cheeks are clenched.
Truly.
You must be Sokolov.
I was about to say, you must be Ames.
Are you one of Vulcan's men?
You'll never get it from me.
No.
I'm a CIA agent.
I've come to escort you back to the other side of the Iron Curtain.
Your CIA?
Yeah.
I was sent by Major Zero, the man who got you out two years ago.
Zero?
I have a message from him.
What is it?
he said to tell you sorry for being so late snake looks so good did he now yeah looks so good what does it mean it means he's a man of his word no you've got no time to this you have to get me out of here before they arrive who's they Colonel Vulgan of grew you will know him as Thunderbolt I know him as Volgan.
Who the hell calls him Thunderbolt?
He's a member of the army's extremist faction.
Who the hell is Thunderbolt?
Ever since the Cuban Missile Crisis two years ago, Khrushchev has been pursuing a policy of peaceful coexistence with the West.
Despite resistance and criticism from hawks in the army and the provincial authorities, Khrushchev has managed to suppress the opposition so far.
has put him in a precarious position.
And on top of that, the tragedy last November.
President Kennedy's assassination.
Dun-dum.
Precisely.
In a sense, Khrushchev has lost his biggest partner and his power base is rapidly crumbling away.
A certain group is plotting to use this opportunity to seize power by rallying the anti-government forces overflowing Khrushchev.
And installing Brezhnev and Khrushchev in this place.
Oh my god, I can't wait for him to say had enough of your kisses.
The mastermind behind this blood is currently Vulcan of the Groove.
He has control over another secret weapons research facility much like this one, OKB812, known as the Gronin Design Bureau, and is using it to further his plans.
But that is not enough to satisfy him.
Okay, I can't scream, though, because my voice is still recovering from this weekend, but I'll do it.
I'll do my best.
My voice is recovering from this whole weekend.
I can't help it.
The intelligence says that they are going to make their move during the test.
And the soldiers outside.
Exactly.
They wouldn't need that many men just to keep me inside.
It's like a pillow in my mouth.
Their orders were to prevent Colonel Vulcan from capturing me.
Hmm.
Wormhole so collapsed.
Yeah.
We have the technology in nine years.
Vulcan will come.
I'm sure of it.
You must get me back.
I'm sure of it too.
Holy!
By the way, your Russian is superb.
Where did you learn to speak it?
from my mentor i need to take off the camels before these america is truly a frightening country having second thoughts you just smirr oh sorry oh gosh
keep smirking
major this is snake sokolov is safe with me he's doing fine no injuries good work yeah I gotta get some of your locals and the locals Roger what about the sentries I managed to get past them I see I did what about the boss we lost contact with the boss some time ago what happened it's probably just a weak signal just hurry and get Sokolov out of there oh oh oh no no no no no no no no no no no no no
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is so insane to see still.
I'm still not over this.
I'm still, I can't believe I'm playing this game right now.
Oh no.
He's coming.
He's almost here.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't look.
I don't think I should look.
But I want to take it all in.
Oh, I shouldn't look.
No, no.
I'm scared.
Why is Sokolov moving like that?
Because he's a silly guy.
He's a silly Willy.
Oh no, no, wait, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
Sorry.
We made it last.
You, you're from the Ocelot unit of Spetsnaz.
That's major to you.
here
soldier he's the ocelot command that's major ocelot to you why does he do that why does he do that why does he do I
Sokolov is ours Get out of here And Ocelot never lets his prey escape What Ouch
Oh yeah Oh that's some fancy Shoot
Oh Sorry I have to bite something
Don't do it.
Oh,
I can't say it feels good to kill a comrade, even if it is for the grue.
Sokolov, take cover.
Sokolov's so bald.
He's presenting.
He's fucked.
Oh, no.
Oh, why does he look at him like that?
Oh, my God.
You're not the boss, are you?
Ugh.
Do it.
Do the thing.
Such a freak.
He's such a freak.
Everyone laugh at him That gun
If you're not the boss Then die Oh stupid Oh my It's happening
Major!
Leave it!
Shoot the other one!
We
need to have more tranquilizer resistance training.
Ha!
Oh my god!
His eyes were...
I love him.
Impossible!
You ejected the first bullet by hand, didn't you?
I see what you were trying to do.
But testing a technique you've only heard about in the middle of battle wasn't very smart.
You were asking to have your gun jam on you, huh?
Besides, I don't think you're cut out for an automatic in the first place.
You tend to twist your elbow to absorb the recoil.
That's more of a revolver technique.
You filthy American dog!
My man is not okay.
But that was some fancy shooting.
You're pretty good.
Pretty good.
You could see every neuron in his brain activate.
You can't believe how it's ever...
Literally the course of his life has just changed.
You sense to that.
Major, do you read me?
I read you.
Young guns stun us a lot.
I've run into a few snags.
These guys were after Sokolov too.
Apparently they were taking orders from the Gru Colonel named Volgan.
I need some water.
Part of an internal Soviet power struggle according to Sokolov.
Something between the KGB and Gru.
Between Khrushchev's supporters and Volgan's.
Sokolov was being guarded by the KGB and hunted by Gru.
snake it sounds like this could be even hotter than Cuba I don't worry we'll try the paradox the whole thing stinks I agree you'd better worry we'll try Sokolov ran off by himself but I'll catch up to him we're counting on you hmm I got him I just put a big old glop of chapstick in my mouth oh we got that other gun let's try it oh wait I have to put in my inventory.
My backpack.
We could blow him up with a grenade.
We could blow him up.
Let's try that.
Wait, let me put on the unlimited.
Wait.
Oh, I like it.
I like it, I like it
He's real jiggly
One thing I think I'm gonna forget to do in this game though Is do more of the codex So Try not to be too spammy about it But you can remind me, you know You can remind me Sometimes
Wait, what?
I'm a genius.
Oh my god.
Wait, move, snake.
Move, snake.
Move.
Okay, hold on.
Wait.
Put away.
Now for my final
trick oh no
i need to move over snake a little bit
tuxedo yeah sorry wait no no uh ah sorry it's not my intention oh i'm getting hungry oh i should also put away my okay how do i is there like a quick okay that's how you put it away quickly got it okay oh tuxedo
Okay, do I have to, like, get it washed?
Oh.
Are those grenades on your outfit?
Yep.
No,
stop.
Stop.
Snake.
Okay, hold on.
It, from behind it just looks like the...
He is sparkling!
Oh, because we're clean.
Shut up.
That's so cute.
We're sparkling clean.
Okay,
from the back, though, it just looks like the scientist outfit.
Okay, no, no.
Let's eat some food.
Let's eat our giant Anaconda.
Tasty.
Okay, I need, like, the exact correct angle.
Not in his crotch, please.
This is family friendly.
I just want him, like, staring at his face, you know?
I want to really...
Oh, wait.
This is actually even better.
Because he's, like, looking down on him.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, my gosh.
You take too big of turns, Snake.
Look at his...
Oh, gosh.
Oh.
Look at...
I'm not okay I'm not okay okay this should be good all right oops wrong viewer just kidding okay he looks so cute oh oh he looks like he's about to grab him
okay that doesn't really do anything
whoa I wish I could change it to night time What's this do?
Whoa, freaky.
Wow, now I'm just testing all the features.
That probably made the bitrate go crazy.
What's the most romantic?
Maybe this, we'll go with legacy.
Okay.
Okay, let's kill him.
Let's kill him, boys.
I let's actually this is good practice for the for it too wait see you think I should save first save?
haki paramedic oh oh wait wait this is the actual save button save in the game snake yes
Snake, do you know the creature from the Black Lagoon?
Nope, never heard of it.
These scientists are investigating a place deep in the Amazon called the Black Lagoon.
And they get picked off one after the other by this fishman thing.
And there was this scene when the heroine is going for a swim and the creature sneaks up on her from underwater.
Yeah, the save is so fast.
I thought my heart was going to stop.
I mean, of course, the 3D effects and It came from outer space were a lot more intense, but...
It wouldn't be referring to you coming from outer space, would it?
How rude.
I seem so mean.
Why do you say that?
Yeah.
Because no one on Earth could be as charming as you.
Fine.
I'll just get to the point, Snake.
The Snake rules.
Ooh, la la.
Just imagining you swimming in those jungle rivers makes me think of you being attacked by a fishman.
So stinkin' smooth.
Fishmen aren't the only things that'll attack you in the water.
Really be careful out there.
Okay.
And don't be attacking any pretty girls going for a swim.
him either are you calling me a fish man you started suck enough okay now we kill him
oh we okay so if you hold it down it does
you've created a time paradox your snake you can't go changing the future like that I love that that is
Campbell.
So good.
Series over.
No.
Okay.
okay let's get out of our pristine shiny oh i do have a cut on my face though from what oh sorry i keep pressing the wrong button from what though from what do our plus 50 grenade
why do we have why our battle damage
Bye, Ocelot.
I'll see you again later.
Mwah!
Wait, I'm going to pick him up a little bit.
Oh!
Hello?
Where'd he go?
Wait, where am I?
Wait, I'm...
Oh, there we go.
Wait, oh, that's what I'm doing.
Thank you.
Come here.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
He is so ragdolled.
I'm stuck.
He's so floppy.
Okay, I'll put you down now, buddy.
Why is he so floppy?
It's like he's awake or something and he's like, this is how a unconscious man would move.
Kick him.
It is him when I wake up.
He's having good dreams.
Okay, before we go to the bridge, did I grab everything in here?
I can't remember.
Whoop.
I can't remember if I grabbed everything around here.
Also, where the heck is Gokko and Kedotan?
Haven't seen them either.
Are they under the house?
Stairs to the room.
roof.
That guy's still up here.
We got some birds.
Wait.
Got a birdie.
That was so dramatic.
It was Oh, there's a snake.
And a rat.
Oh my god, look at him scuttle.
Look at him scuttle away.
Is this the R rat?
Is this the rat?
I like the effect.
It's kind of cool.
It's just rat.
I like the way their little legs move though.
Let's go through here.
I see snakes.
That's a big boy.
Nobody.
Rat.
Now eat them alive.
Where's my knife?
Come here.
How do I...
Oh.
Actually, how do I use it?
Thank you for the redirect.
Thank you.
Hello, hello.
How do I use this?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How's Delta so far?
I love it so far.
Having so much fun.
Touch.
You guys' profile pictures still getting me.
I'm a little laggy, but the game has been great so far.
So I apologize for my leg.
I apologize if I'm wagon.
Hello, stop it.
Where is Kedotan and Gakko, though?
We're searching.
Since I have free rain, I'm so curious.
Over here?
Oh, where could they be?
Sokolov's room.
Let's check it.
Wait, can I open these lockers?
Oh.
No, I cannot.
You think Ocelot?
Oh my gosh, everything is so glitchy on my side.
Even my notifs are glitchy.
I think I might have to turn them off, you guys.
I'm sorry.
Not in here.
Huh.
Some tall lockers.
Right?
I was going to say snake is pretty short.
Well, he's not short, but like, you know.
taller characters in the series than him but these are some crazy tall lockers
he's not covered in popsicles he's covered in grenades yeah oh why are you sneaking all of a sudden i didn't press that do you guys have you guys seen them yet kerotan or gako
am i blind the check under the stairs okay because i feel like we would have seen at least one by now hmm
under the stairs
check under there oh i see you that's cute that's a good spot
But Gaka...
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
Kero-Tan, though.
Mysterious.
I mean, uh, wait, no, not Kero-Tan.
Gaka though.
So mysterious.
Hmm.
Oh well.
Oh wait, how do I put the suppressor?
Yes sir.
Uh...
It says I have four left but I can't tell if it's equipped or not.
Someone said it's not.
In the menu.
I can't tell.
So stupid.
Wow that looks like a real hornet's nest.
Thank you guys for all the gifted memberships.
Thank you so so so so much.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you!
One odd.
Wait, you can toggle...
Wait, I can't.
Oh.
I do have the crocodile cap.
I guess it came...
But it's one odd.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You can toggle the display of this item during cutscenes on and off from...
That's nice.
Wait, hold on.
What was I doing?
Oh, the item.
so cute so cute so stinking cute oh my gosh one-eyed croc
i always forget to press a we're crocking it we're crocking it I love that you can hear the when he runs around in the crock suit.
I also saw that if you're wearing the full thing and you go up to guards, they run away.
They're scared of you.
It's Flat Fuck Friday.
Flat Fuck Friday.
Oh,
there we go.
Oh my gosh, he's chomping me.
Eee-ee-ee, tickles.
Okay.
where the oh um what was i doing oh yeah i was trying to figure out how to do my suppressor okay let's not do this because we have a serious cut seat cut seat coming up let's not do this let's do as oh sorry i didn't read that one oh let's just go with go with go with the leaf going with the tea no paint no hat use kettle okay if i got a cute though actually will be so kind of cute in the cutscene but i still need to figure out my surprise we'll figure it out later let's just go do it crock suit too much kettoton hat or kettoton mask exactly how i want it
hi sokolov wait where is it okay those men were from the Ocelot unit.
Yes.
The best crew has to offer.
They said in options, right?
Under what?
Camera shake?
Okay, wait.
I just realized.
Let's do weak for that.
I don't like that kind of stuff.
Show bleeding effects on.
There we go.
I finished.
Calm down.
I'll get you out of here, I promise.
And we've got some of the best back up we could ask look oh wait what is this that's what they were making you build yes the shagohod the treading behemoth a tank capable of launching nuclear IRBM it's too good from that kind of terrain oh yes without support from friendly units a nuclear equipped tank capable of operating solo wow
is that thing finished no this is only the end of phase one it won't be truly finished until we complete phase two phase two the weapon's true form it's so funny if it is completed and the Cold War.
The end of the Cold War.
And then the age of fear will truly begin.
Uh-oh.
The World War.
I had no choice but to cooperate.
I didn't want to die.
I don't want to see Ken or Ty talking about World Wars.
Please, take me to America.
Quickly.
I don't want to see that.
They cannot complete it without my help.
It even looks so good though.
Get up, get up, get up, get up.
Okay.
I'm going to turn it off for this though.
So we can see his expressions and stuff.
I won't do this all the time.
Off.
Okay.
If you enable this setting, please note that displaying such items may interfere with the immersive experience.
experience.
Okay.
I've only fell all in, like, a couple times on this bridge.
After this cutscene is everything that I've played up to, by the way.
I thought you were in the Arctic Sea.
Boss?
Whoa!
Good work, Jack.
What are you doing here?
Sokolov comes with me.
Oh my gosh, I can't wait to see everybody.
Oh, I got the bees!
Is this killing the frame rate?
Yeah!
Lobbies!
my bit rate they
look so good oh my my friends let us fight together again I have waited long for this day we will fight with you once more wake up old man welcome back boss now that all five of us are together it's time we go to the depths of hell itself he's crying
it's raining blood is he crying
spooky oh
Oh, what a joyful scene.
Oh, don't say that.
Colonel Vogan.
Welcome to my country.
And to my unit.
Boss, what is this?
He poses and she does not care.
I'm defecting to the Soviet Union.
Sokolov is a little gift from my new hosts.
Recoilless nuclear warheads.
Recoilless nuclear warheads is actually insane.
These will make a fire.
gift for me this can't be happening who is he another one of your disciples how many disciples do you have huh wasn't I special taking him with us no this one is still just a child too pure for us Cobras baby cracker he has not yet found an emotion to carry into battle what are you talking about think you can pull the trigger oh and
one smooth swoop you're still just a baby
see my face
vulgan's hair looks so strange like i don't think i i guess because of the textures in the original game, I don't imagine him with hair.
So seeing him with hair is so bizarre.
You saved Kero-Tan from that fate.
He must die.
Wait.
He's my apprentice.
I'll take care of him.
Oh, this looks so good.
My goodness, she's so pretty.
It's like he's has hair that babies have.
You can't come with us.
You can't sit with us.
This... Boss... Boss, I changed my mind!
Boss, I changed my mind!
Aww, they have the same gloves on.
The new blood has been...
And took her bandana.
Are we done here?
Now onto Sokolov's research facility.
Baby hair.
Baby hair, baby hair Vulcan.
Vulcan with his baby hair.
Vulcan grew two new strands today.
Yeah, Vulcan's face looks incredible.
I think the only one I'm a little lukewarm on is the pain.
Because I feel like his face underneath looks less of like a face and more of like a...
It looks kind of almost like PNG-ish.
But...
But everyone else looks really, really good.
Guess we'll see later.
Yeah, he's our first guy, so let's check him out later.
Oh, Snake.
Snake, can you hear me?
Yeah.
Just barely.
Emergency medical treatment.
Can you move?
Oh, wow.
You've got to get those rooms treated.
Hang in there.
He's fine now.
He's like, ow, ow.
Okay, back to position.
Just relax and it'll all be over.
Care menu time!
Stay with me.
I've seen people in worse shape before.
Just a headache.
Think you can handle it?
Major.
The boss.
affected we'll talk about that later first we've got to get you patched up okay here we go first open the survival viewer with the survival viewer button if you select cure you can start the treatment look at this feeling is divided into two types of treatment it's so hard medicine and surgical procedures your injuries include a fractured left elbow and rib bone and lacerations on your upper arms right elbow and abdomen they need to be fixed using surgical treatment treatment.
Move the healing cursor with a movement stick to the affected part of your body and press the inner button.
Once you've selected the affected area, use the movement stick to select the medical item and then press the inner button.
Then press the inner button.
With this method, you can use items to help your recovery process.
To treat a bone fracture, first secure the affected area with a fastener and then wrap it in bandages.
That should do it.
Okay.
For lacerations, you'll need disinfectant to clean the wound, sutures to stitch it up, Sinking voice by Kermit.
Because he is with the back.
If you do everything I mentioned, the wound should heal completely.
Understood?
Yeah.
Stay with me.
Go into the survival viewer and treat those wounds.
Okay!
Cure.
Oh, look.
Is freaking dead.
Snake!
Wow.
Oh my gosh, hold on.
Let me just appreciate the beauty.
Wait, can we see?
You can see him right there!
Oh my god!
You can see a skeleton right there!
That's crazy!
Yeah, take a picture.
Oh my gosh.
That's him!
Check his pulse.
Look, he's throwing paper.
Uh, wait.
Uh, hide.
Cool.
Okay.
Sorry, Snake.
I'll get you cured up.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
I just press up.
That's kind of nice.
Instead of holding it, like, for the camouflage.
Select cure.
Okay, we know this.
We know this.
Oh, he's not looking so high.
All right.
Suffering from a deep cut.
We need...
We need to...
Wait.
We need to disinfect it.
We need to stop bleeding.
We need to bandage it.
I'm going way out of order.
Is that the floating spooky glasses guy?
Stabilized!
Bandage.
Okay, we got a cut.
We got a bandage.
Oh, whoops.
I forgot to stop the bleeding.
And disinfect it.
Uh, uh, uh, disinfect it.
Stop bleeding.
A bandage.
So, we're way out of order.
It's so out of order!
Um...
There we go.
Oh, more bone fracture.
Bandage.
Okay, we're fine.
It doesn't matter.
Yeah, you chew on that.
Someday you chew on a tree bark.
He's so handsome.
I know, right?
Yeah, I use that.
Good idea.
Good job, Snake.
We're coming to get you now.
Just stay where you are.
We'll drop a recovery balloon.
Can you set it up?
Fulton me.
Oh.
And I...
Uh-oh.
Whoa, that's a great shot.
Shagohod.
He's so limp.
Papers!
Scissors!
Always go with rock.
Good old rock.
I can't beat that.
Can't beat Rob, doesn't beat it.
I wonder what this game is like in Ultra.
Oh no.
There he is, my boy.
He's not a freak considering his entire life.
Thank you so much for the gifted pod, thank you.
Oh.
What a freak.
This guy's the freaks of all, the freak of all freaks.
Excellent.
A great success.
Thanks to the boss and her cobras, I have both Sokolov and the Shagohad.
There's a smelly woman behind you.
I love that picture of it.
What are we going to do with the girl?
Who is she?
Apparently she's Sokolov's woman Ooh la la Sokolov must have the The charm of A Greek god
She's a nice catch Yeah she is I'll take her I'll take her Not so fast my dear Is this a lipstick Oh A
kiss of death.
You KGB.
We may be able to use her.
Their outfits match.
She has Spunk.
She's so pretty.
Good lord, she's so pretty.
Oh, no, everybody's so attractive.
It's unfair.
Shall we take her back to the base?
Perhaps we should.
We have no further use the Silkolovs research facility.
I think it's time I gave this girl some toy.
They're winning!
Let them twin!
Oh, oh no.
Even if they are our enemies, they're still our countrymen.
But it won't be me that pulled the trigger.
It'll be our friend, the American defector.
You're going to nuke your fellow Russians?
Remember the Alamo.
Colonel.
Little baby.
Beam
of the guy getting flashbanged.
Oh, no.
He didn't.
Oh, yes, he did.
Yeah, the final bit is human.
Minor spelling mistake.
Virtuous mission.
completed all right we're out of we're out of the tutorial so this is the new opening this is not the original one if we played on legacy style we would have the original one but this is the new one which I think is also the new yeah it's the new what's it called with darkness the re-recording as well but it's still Still Cynthia.
I'm searching and I'll melt into you.
What a fear in my heart.
I don't see anything I can control.
Oh there's some guys!
I give my life not for honor but for you.
In Korean!
In my time, there'll be no one else.
Crime, it's the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream.
They have the peace.
There it is.
I'm literally needing a snake.
Someday you go through the rain And someday you'll feed on a tree frog This ordeal, the trial to survive For the day we feed alive I give life I love, I love, I love, I love In my time There'll be no one
Crime It's the way I fly To you I'm still in a dream Snail
Wait, I forgot to press
No sneeter button
That's kind of sad Maybe in the original there is Like if you do the legacy Cynthia still got it Her voice is still so beautiful After all these years Oh my god ocean altitude 30,000 feet you guys shut the fuck up please i don't care about your opinion go to twitter or reddit drone oil pressure and voltage are nominal payload oxygen supply is nominal power supply to payload any free system shows no problems no gusts all systems go for drone detachment snake we can't risk a halo jump this time around airspace security has gotten tighter since we were last here we can't get as close to the ground as we did during the virtuous mission so instead we'll be using one of our newest weapons snake you're being given an honor on par with alan shepherd this is our last chance show your patriotism if you fail you'll be back in a hospital bed again waiting for the firing squad
sorry i wasn't pressing r2 i was bad so how does it feel to be a patient in one of the most advanced Sorry, I forgot to press R2.
I forgot to press R2.
I'll never get better with them assaulting me day and night.
I always say R2, I don't know why.
Must be part of the top brass's inquiry.
More like an interrogation.
According to them, I'm a traitor and an accomplice to the boss's defection.
They're just looking for a scapegoat.
Does that mean they're after you too?
It's okay, we'll see the other posters.
Neither one of us is going to be made a national hero out of this.
Does this mean Fox is going to die?
This fox is still one step ahead of the house.
The reason I came to see you today Jack It's time for Fox to clear its name.
What are you talking about?
The situation has changed.
We've still got a chance to come out of this one alive.
Yeah, what kind of chance?
Don't get too excited Fox died.
Here, have a cigar.
It's Cuba.
Where'd he go?
He's a ghost.
This morning I had a meeting with the CIA.
They decided when they're going to execute us.
Something even bigger.
What's that?
Yesterday, the White House received an unexpected call.
Okay.
President Johnson?
Yes, I hear you, Mr. Chairman.
It was a hotline call from Khrushchev to President Johnson.
They're so bad.
From the head of the Soviet Union?
That's right.
A few days ago, one of our countries main design bureaus, OKB 754, was destroyed in a nuclear explosion.
At about the same time, our anti-aircraft radar picked up a signature that appeared to come from one of your military aircraft.
Does any of this sound familiar to you?
In retaliation, I have placed our armed forces on secondary alert.
Depending on your response, The president's voice acting always gets me in the scene.
Both are so funny.
And unleash Armageddon.
Doesn't sound Russian.
With the help of your predecessor, I was able to survive a Cuban incident.
But my power is not as great as it once was.
If I am to survive this crisis, I must have your full cooperation.
I contacted you myself.
Did you know that one of our soldiers defected to your country a week ago?
I'm American.
So you haven't heard that.
The man who arranged the defection was a group colonel by the name of Yevgeny Borosovich Volgin.
Yevgeny.
Of the Brezhne faction.
Go on.
I love this scene.
Who is the soldier?
Her name is the boss.
The boss.
a living legend during World War two she was the one who led us to victory in that war in Russia you know hers boy a voter boy a voter the boss the mother of your special forces yes that's the one she took two miniature nuclear shells along with her the boss took two miniature nuclear shells I'm afraid so I believe they were a gift for her new hosts the Davy Crockett atomic battle group delivery system was completed two years ago like freaks out over it serious problems were found with the launchers range and precision although they were mass-produced they've never been deployed in battle but Sokolos research facility was completely wiped out the whole area is polluted I can only offer you my deepest condolences over this terrible tragedy So,
the boss, with Colonel Vulcan's help, stole two experimental nuclear shells and took them with her as a gift when she defected.
Then, shortly thereafter, Sokolos Design Lab, a top-secret military research facility, was destroyed by one of these weapons.
Am I right so far?
Yes, that's correct.
He, like, crosses so close to, like, a Hispanic accent so much.
right as well.
That's correct.
We were not involved in any way.
Then what was a US military aircraft doing on our radar screen?
It was clearly in a violation of our airspace and yet you say it was not acting under your orders.
That's correct.
It's historically accurate.
You expect me to believe that this was all the work of a single soldier.
I believe that's right.
I don't know what else to tell you.
I don't know.
The army insists that this is all a ploy on your I've said it once and I'll say it again.
Our government had nothing to do with it.
I'll tell you what our government had nothing to do with it.
However, I'm afraid my power over the military has weakened since the Cuban incident.
I will need some kind of proof that this was not the action of the American government.
You have one week.
You must catch the boss yourselves and recover the remaining nuclear device.
find some way to prove your innocence.
Blitzar, welcome.
Thank you.
I also love that.
Prove our innocence.
Yes, preferably something painful.
Prove to me that this is not merely another one of your tricks.
President Johnson sells propane and propane accessories.
The boss should be close to Colonel Volgan.
How about a little co-action?
I would not expect too much if I were you.
The political situation here is unstable.
And Colonel Volgan is a member of of faction which seeks to topple my government one week you have only one week and if it is not too much to ask do something about Vulcan as well what is that supposed to mean nothing means nothing call it a modest gentleman's agreement to ensure our continued relationship what if we can't prove our innocence then I will be unable to I will be ousted and they will seek their revenge.
A nuclear attack on the United States.
Leave the disposal of this situation entirely to your discretion, Mr. President.
Mr. President.
If you fail, it will mean the beginning of a new world war.
We just got out of a world war.
Put it simply, in order to avoid a full-scale nuclear conflict, That proved that America was not involved in that explosion.
Guys are so annoying.
And eliminating the boss ourselves will prove America's innocence.
The higher-ups have decided that you're the only one capable of pulling this off.
You were her last apprentice.
Screw this one up and we'll both be six feet under.
There's no choice.
God damn it, another one.
Like chill for two seconds.
Are the Russians going to be helping us?
Oh, wait!
The KGB has promised...
There you guys go!
Oh, Yumi Kikuchi!
That's it.
You're welcome.
They've also put us in touch with a couple of insiders.
Insiders?
There was a defection in September 1960.
We ended up getting the poster after all!
You mean the two NSA co-workers who went over to the Soviet Union?
She's so crazy, right?
Since then, they've apparently been training with the KGB for exactly this kind of situation.
They're codenames for Adam and Eva.
I've been told that Adam has infiltrated Vulcan's ranks.
We've also arranged for him to provide you with an escape route.
You'll need to rendezvous with him when you get there.
Your
English is so good!
Suddenly, we're playing is combat.
It's fast.
Estimated airspeed exceeding Mach 3.
Bearing south.
I'm about to lose it.
The girly poster is still there?
It's been updated with, like, new pictures of the models from the original.
Some of them even show them with their kids.
It's so sweet.
But if you play Legacy, it's the original pictures.
You're right!
Stick with trigger and you'll make it.
I need the little brackets in your for your super chat around your message Oh gosh Seeing it with the bandana now.
Oh my god.
It's so good So good
This is snake.
Do you read man?
loud and clear I have to keep adjusting the volume sorry guys I got blown pretty far off target snake let's go over your mission objectives one more time rescue Sokolov find out what's happened to the Shagahod then destroy it and finally eliminate the very photogenic picture of the Shagahod this mission will be codenamed Operation Snake Eater because I'll be taking on the boss in our Cobra unit right don't forget about Colonel Vulcan I'm not a hired killer her.
I know, but that was the Kremlin's demand.
Demand?
You mean it wasn't just a request.
What's it to us if the Khrushchev regime is threatened by the Colonel and his faction?
I don't want to go into the operation.
I don't want to do it.
I'm too sad.
And what are the CIA's demands?
Our priorities are the rescue of Sokolov and the destruction of the Shagahod.
Roger that, Major Tom.
Hold on, Snake.
What now?
I'm changing my code name.
It turns out Tom the most auspicious choice what do you want to see a change well the truth is when i chose my code name i picked the wrong one the wrong one did you ever see the movie the great escape came out last year you're so silly missed that one anyway it's based on a true story about prisoners who escaped from a pow camp in nazi germany the prisoners dig three tunnels as part of their plan but the nazis find two of the tunnels before they're finished the prisoners succeed in escaping by using the last remaining tunnel the names of those three tunnels were dick harry and tom i get it you use the name of the tunnel they escaped in as your code name because you thought it would bring you good luck yes that's exactly right at least we got the wrong one but i got the name wrong the one they escaped him was harry major harry doesn't roll off the tongue well though discovered by the nazis before it was finished i watched the movie again just to make sure when did you have i was dying
in the hospital and you're watching movies name to use so what should i call you do you have any urgency major let's just use zero like we've been doing all along all right like my goodness zero it is updated we'll start over from square one from square zero my frequency is one four zero point eight five oh important research true medic is with us again on this mission is this her last chance too if we fail she'll have her it's more or less the same you know what that might be for the better her frequency is the same as during the virtuous mission one four five profile pick looks so good oh my god you slaying mission data as well just like the last time that frequency is also the same one four zero point nine six and there's one more person on your support team his name is mr sigint yeah he's an expert on the latest in weapons and equipment technology you'll be going up against Some of the world's most advanced weaponry when you infiltrate the research facility.
If you have any questions, just ask him.
His frequency.
His special talent at parties?
Counting the number of hairs on his head.
Mr. Siggant, got it.
Adam, your KGB contact, is waiting for you at the abandoned factory up ahead.
Okay.
The same factory Sokolov was being held in last week.
Yes, meet up with Adam first.
He's cleared the way for you to rescue Sokolov.
How will I know this Adam guy when I see him?
The whole area has been polluted by the fallout from that nuclear blast.
No one else would dare come close.
The password is, Who are the Patriots?
And Lali Lululelo.
Lali Lululelo.
Gotcha.
You've been equipped with a 45 for this mission.
Be careful.
It's noisy.
I thought standard Fox procedure was procure-on-site weapons acquisition.
The circumstances are different this time.
You're now on an official mission for the United States government.
It would be necessary to make your presence known to a certain extent to the Khrushchev regime at the very least.
The Patriots.
But remember, this is still a sneaking mission.
Snake, if you fail this mission, it will mean an all-out nuclear war.
Keep that in mind and proceed with extreme caution.
Commencing Operation Snake Eater.
Wow.
And this is where I started playing in New York, and then they kicked me out.
Like, um, you're only allowed to play up to, um, you're only allowed to play to the end of Virtuous Mission.
Because I kept skipping all the cutscenes.
I was like, wait, but I have still 10 minutes.
They were like, well, it's only 10 minutes.
I said, okay.
And I left.
Let's see what other animals we got in here.
Whoa, it's so dark.
I did turn up the brightness a little bit.
Oh, I'm on a snake.
Whoa!
Sensitive little guy.
Holy.
I see you.
Wait, I don't have a suppressor anymore?
That kind of sucks.
Is that the Boko Boko?
All our fruit.
Wait, hold on.
Paramedic, tell me what this is.
Now!
Paramedic.
Snake, it's so good to hear from you again.
I'm hungry.
It's been a week, hasn't it?
Four days, actually.
Me?
I visited you in the hospital.
You were still unconscious, though.
Then you must have seen me naked.
Yeah, but you were all wrapped up in bandages and tubes, so I couldn't do anything, but look.
Better luck next time.
Let's hope so.
But seriously, don't forget that you were like that until just yesterday.
In fact, you really shouldn't even be on this mission.
Keep an eye on your stamina gauge.
If you start to run low, don't push yourself.
replenish your stamina and try not to get yourself hurt if you're wounded or get bitten by a venomous animal go into the survival viewer immediately and treat yourself using cure yeah yeah I can see you still know how to nag you're welcome and I can you still don't know when to get your mouth shut snake by the way I heard you're going to lose your medical license if this mission fails yes there was talk of that but the mission won't fail will it Of course not.
Yeah, well fair.
I believe in you.
But you know what?
I really don't care about my medical license.
Didn't they use that to force you to participate in this operation?
No, I volunteered.
Why?
So that I could watch over you.
Huh.
Snake, you're the best agent I've ever seen.
But you push yourself too hard.
You're reckless.
You're the best agent I've ever seen.
Someone has to stop you from getting into trouble.
I'm like running around in a frogman.
mask so that's why i volunteered i mean you couldn't ask for a better guardian angel than me right thanks stop right there you can thank me when you get back all right all right hold on let's call her again snake unlike the virtuous mission this is a night operation you'll be encountering nocturnal animals that you didn't encounter your last and we gotta call sigint too some of them are venomous like the king cobra so be careful okay if you get bitten by a venomous animal the poison will spread through your body and rapidly drain your life gauge if that's the case go into the cure screen and survival viewer immediately we got to get through a couple serum got it a couple codex though to get to our fruit i see you caught yourself a reticulated python the reticulated python is said to be the longest snake in the world the biggest ones can grow up to 10 they're still very dangerous so be careful around them they have a highly ferocious temperament and they can swallow whole even large
animals like deer and pigs their most distinguishing feature is the mesh pattern of their scales this pattern acts as a highly effective natural camouflage if you think there might be a reticulated she said this at the panel too otherwise she was like reticulated python it's a huge snake but you should be able to capture it alive by using the tranquilizer gun.
I'll bet if you capture one and throw it at an enemy, it'll give them a good scare.
I do.
Actually!
But how do they taste?
Huh?
Did they taste good?
You're actually going to eat one.
Wait, we should throw some on the guys that are going to come up.
What was that?
Nothing.
Let's see what the guide says.
Ah, you're in luck.
It says they taste pretty good.
Cannibal.
Good.
I can hardly wait.
Okay, hold on.
I see you found some Siberian ink cap mushrooms.
The Siberian ink cap is a mushroom from the ink cap family.
Ink cap.
Its life cycle is transitory.
As soon as the score is mature, the cap starts to turn black, liquefy, and melt away.
And that's why they call it an ink cap.
That's right.
It doesn't really turn to liquid, but you get the idea.
In its immature state, before it melts away, it's valued as a source of food.
Just be sure not to eat them while you're doing it.
drinking alcohol.
Why's that?
Ink caps contain coprin, which inhibits the function of aldehyde dehydrogenase.
Ink cap.
This prevents the body from breaking down alcohol, causing a buildup of a citaldehyde.
Meaning?
Meaning it will give you the hangover from hell.
Oh, wait a minute.
What?
You think I'd drink alcohol in the middle of a mission?
Wouldn't you?
Hell no.
Well, I'm knocking a shot back now what just teasing you she's so flirty where's your sense of humor i need a drink they're so flirty i see you found a yabloko yabloko yabloko what now yabloko maloko it's a russian name that roughly translates as milk apple it's a type of star apple the juice isn't this one milk hence the name doesn't he not like it one and a half lengthwise you'll see a star-shaped ring radiating out from the center mokoko hence the star right the star-shaped part has a gelatinous texture and is said to be especially tasty sounds useful i'm not yabloko maloko i'm mokoko did you say something no uh back to the mission all right second nice to meet you yo you're snake aren't SICK IT!
I heard that you're an expert on weapons, equipment, and cutting-edge technology.
This is my first time seeing him.
I am the expert on weapons, equipment, and cutting-edge technology.
Hell yeah.
I'm the guy that designed your trinket gun, active sonar, and motion detector.
If you want to know anything about weapons or equipment you find in the field, just send me a message and ask.
He's the expert.
Later.
Nice.
Wait, I want to get something.
snakes actually that we can throw at there's going to be some guys coming up and since I don't have a suppressor I can see the Gakko spinning from here it's so cute I want to oh wait no wait I don't have I don't have it I have a stun grenade but I'm not going to waste it we'll use it on the guys actually that might be better okay just kidding
you can attach the suppressor from this menu oh Oh, wait, because, yeah, I have nine.
Oh, I see it.
Thank you.
Okay, now we have it attached.
Okay, oh, wait.
It's the exact same as the original.
Golly, I'm dumb.
Sorry.
I'm so not used to using the D-pad over the triggers for everything.
It's kind of strange.
Okay.
does the grenade camel work with stuff that's a great question that's a really good quote wait yeah that's a real oh i keep always forgetting let's see
it does oh wow can he change the button layout okay i'm okay with it wait that's so op no i don't remember when the guy uh i don't think there's anyone around yet i still have a kettotan is very difficult to find wait that means i can get the if i have if i have unlimited i can get these snakes you know uh does it work
something oh yeah baby okay so now okay oh my bad long menu um backpack oh wait did it kill him no we'll add the reticulated python we'll add two of them
it's not to eat Where are they?
Uh-oh.
Maybe I did kill them.
Was the light too strong?
Oh,
under weapon.
Oh, there, wait.
Meat.
Dang it.
It'll still distract them, but I wanted to throw...
I wanted to throw the snake at them, you know, to make them all spooked.
We should be hearing a horse.
There.
Look at that guy.
Holy cow, it's so violent.
I see you caught yourself a green tree python.
Yes.
The green tree python isn't venomous, so no need to worry.
It's fairly docile too, so I don't think it's likely to attack you.
Australia and New Zealand.
It's a really pretty green color and it lives... oh my God.
What's wrong?
Snake, what did I just say?
They come from Australia and New Zealand.
No, after that.
They're a really pretty green color.
I thought so.
What was I thinking?
Seeing a snake and calling it pretty?
What's wrong with that?
Yeah, what's wrong with that?
Everything.
When a normal woman sees a snake she's supposed to scream or get sick or something like that.
that and you think you're normal what was that nothing oh i think it's all your fault geez i'm sorry am i not normal what do you mean i love lizards and snakes no i i just wanted you to tell me how it tastes how should i know come on woman was awfully pretty though just tell me how it tastes
I'm gonna get some water after this.
Just tell me how it tastes, woman.
I've already been playing for three hours, and I'm only starting a snake eater mission now.
Oopsie!
I'm having too much fun just being silly.
Horse.
Haunts.
Looks like death wasn't ready for you yet.
Boss!
Boss?
That arm still hurt?
A little.
What are you doing here?
Boss, no!
I love her sneaking, Suto.
So pretty.
Go home.
Drew and my sons are waiting up ahead.
You don't have a prayer of finishing your mission.
You're not even armed.
Well, I was.
I'm not your boss anymore.
There's nothing for you here.
Go home.
back to your boss there's no need to prove that you're a virtuous here the go home hurts so bad this isn't America
it's personal that should stir things up a bit you'd better hurry
You're 60 miles south of here.
You ought to be able to run that far.
Why'd you defect?
I didn't.
I'm loyal to the end, to my purpose.
What about you, Jack?
What's it going to be?
Loyalty to your country or loyalty to me?
Your country or your old mentor?
The mission or your beliefs?
Your duty to your unit or your personal feelings?
You don't know the truth yet.
But sooner or later, you'll have to choose.
I don't expect you to forgive me.
But you can't defeat me either.
You know me too well.
I'll sing out.
Just look at that bandana.
If you can't put the past behind you, you won't survive.
I'll happy birthday after the tag team.
Ow, so!
Now,
go home.
Oh my god!
Hurts like hell.
Solidus guy, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
I read you, Snake.
I was ambushed by the boss.
You were what?
The drone's been shot to hell.
It's up in flames.
That's not good.
Enemy scouts are going to come looking for you.
Yeah, I know.
But what was the boss doing here in the first place?
There's got to be a leak somewhere.
No, that's impossible.
The man the boss is working with Volgin isn't exactly on speaking terms with Khrushchev.
I lost my gun.
The boss destroyed it.
My gun.
Snake, I know how you're feeling.
It's hard for me to believe, too, that a legendary hero like the boss would go over to the Russians.
But she'd double cross us like this.
But that's how it is and if you don't accept it, you'll never be able to beat her That's not the problem in terms of sheer technique.
I'll never be able to beat her.
I know that all too well You've got to do it snake.
She's your enemy and your objective.
No We were together for ten years and now you tell me she's my enemy.
Yeah Hurry to the factory where Adam is waiting Scouts have probably already been sent out.
This is so gray fox all at snake.
You've lost your weapon, right?
solid stink had to go through the same thing whatever you do don't let them see you so sad oh oh oh grass grass grass my camo is not very high
let's also do sonar
ah what the hell is this oh my god it's from over there HQ?
HQ.
This is HQ.
Control here.
I thought it was going to be from over there!
I completely lost where I was looking at.
Oh,
it even highlights them.
That's kind of nice.
Will this work?
Uh.
Are they down?
Where am I?
Oh.
Anyway.
Oh, shit.
Who saw me?
Nobody saw me.
What the?
Me into my eyes.
Sorry, I can't help it.
I have unlimited.
I have to use them.
I can't shoot them.
kill them what if they run out well you can look away after doing it I have to make sure it is I
did attach this oh she took my gun I forgot um hold on I'm gonna where is that guy anyway forgot she disabled it I was gonna go is he coming back what is he doing up there what is he why is he rocking the what is he doing
oh he's he's just chilling oh he's walking the slowest walk ever
that's so funny i was if he was turned around i was gonna go seek you see him but
There he is.
I'll look away.
Here, guys.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Oh, my bad.
Look away.
Oops.
I should have gotten him, though.
Why?
Ah, this didn't work this time.
I'm also, I can't see she.
Oh shoot!
What the?
Ah!
It didn't work, everybody.
Uh, oh.
Ow!
You can't catch me!
I have unlimited grenades!
I keep forgetting I don't have a gun.
grenades time to see attractive ladies Adam where are you is there anybody here I can't remember if this area has people or not I can't this is HQ patrol here we've lost sight of the I hear them like behind me.
It's kind of fun.
I can't remember if anybody's here or not.
Take some bird juice.
Wait, what?
What's here?
Oh, I think it's all underneath.
Oh, action button.
I see you, but I can't get you.
Lame.
Absolutely lame.
Oh, there they are.
Wait, I see all these guys.
You see them over there?
That's so funny.
Can I throw something at them?
Hmm.
Maybe like here.
Why are they so slow?
Oh, I see them right there.
Bink, bink.
Where are they?
Oh.
I'm just gonna...
Hmm.
Put on the sunglasses.
We'll just wait it up.
You did not.
No, you didn't.
Yeah, you're seeing things.
I see.
Yeah, you don't see, actually.
Stupid liar?
I don't think the sunglasses change your vision at all.
The caution's almost over.
It's okay.
I think I just go back into this room where Sokolov was.
I don't remember this part very well.
I hear him, but I don't see where he's standing.
Return to your position.
There they go.
Is anyone still here?
I want that.
I want the items.
I'm just going to drop.
If I have to fight anybody, we'll just see QCM.
Drop.
No, not climb.
I'm stupid.
Oh, sorry, I didn't see somebody raided me.
Thank you.
Whoa.
Thank you so- oh, gave me okay.
Thank you.
Thanks for the raid.
Whoever raided me.
Thank you so much.
We got the box.
We got copper box.
I got smoke grenades.
Oh, shit.
There are still guys here.
I keep thinking that's a guy.
It's definitely not.
Mine detector.
The mine D.
Where in the heck do I meet her?
I don't remember.
Thermal goggles.
There's so many little critters underneath me.
Oh, there we go.
I was like, how do I trigger the cutscene again?
I don't remember.
I'm stupid.
RB,
RB, RB.
Thank you so much for the thank you.
Thank you.
Sorry I'm late.
Cut the engine.
They'll hear us.
Are you the agent they sent?
I thought you were supposed to be a man.
Adam couldn't make it.
Nice and hydrated.
Yeah, I gotta go after this cutscene.
I'll go.
Who are the Patriots?
Uh-oh.
Answer me!
Get down!
I think my computer's starting to get fried.
Holy cow!
Gumbar PC There Is your answer Not really Not really
This area is perfect for pistol vintages Oh she's so Oh my gosh she's so pretty
Just staring straight at him Thank you The name's Eva Here Oh, they kept the old name.
That's so interesting.
Excuse me.
He just doesn't even try to look up at her.
Oh, wait.
I love this boat so much.
I want to see him nerd out.
What happened to Adam?
What's your code name?
It's Snake.
Snake, huh?
Well, I'm Eva.
Are you here to tempt me?
Eva.
What happened to Adam?
Now he's shy.
Colonel Vogan is a very suspicious man.
He decided Adam wasn't the right person for this mission.
And you were?
Yes.
Why?
Because I can do things he can't.
I heard you used to be a codebreaker for the NSC.
say i was four years ago i defected to the soviet union with adam mauser military the broom handle his little smirks are killing me nice to have when you're on a you held it sideways and used the muzzle jump to create a horizontal sweep that was impressive bet you've never seen that technique in the west it's imitation isn't it such a nerd i love him it's Ah
Don't worry though the one I've got for you is American made
Oh Yeah, let him 45 huh?
Oh Yeah, handle that.
Oh, oh, yeah, incredible.
Oh, yeah, do you like it?
The feeding ramp is polished to a mirror sheen the slide's been reinforced and the interlock with the frame is tightened for added precision the sight system is original too the thumb safety is extended to make it easier on the finger a long tight trigger with non-slip grooves a ring hammer the base of the trigger guard's been filed down for a higher grip oh yeah and not only that nearly every part of this gun has been expertly crafted and customized I should have put on the Kettoton mask for this
he's nerding out I grabbed it from a Western munitions armory it probably used to belong to one of your officers and there are more where that came from their uniform our uniform you had this with you didn't you better take this too what's that a disguise to make you look like a scientist a disguise Yes.
You're here to rescue Sokolov, right?
Sokolov's still safe then.
Look at her tummy.
He's being forced to continue his work on the Shagohad.
Where?
Oh my god.
At the lab.
They've got a whole army of scientists.
They're developing new weapons.
Can I do experiments on you, ma'am?
You might be able to sneak in.
Can we get Sokolov out of there?
We'll see, won't we?
Tell me how to get to the lab.
the safest way in is from the rear oh from the rear first you'll need to head north through the jungle you'll come to a heliport used for shipping materials pass the heliport and continue north and there will be a large crevice descend into that area and you'll reach a cave move through the cave and you will arrive at a mangrove swamp my god after the swamp there'll be a warehouse me in my stupid grenade camo.
You'll come out just south of the lab.
Ha ha ha ha.
Got it.
It looks like I have caramel apples all over me.
In close range combat, a knife can sometimes be more useful than a gun.
True.
By doing this, I'll be able to hold a knife at the same time and still keep the gun steady.
That way, I can instantly switch between a gun battle and a knife fight.
Right, let's get going.
Wait a minute.
What now?
You must be tired.
Why don't you take a little rest?
I'll be fine.
Oh, immediately is not fine.
You'll never make it in your condition.
It's a jungle out there.
Yeah, and I'm a beast.
There's still an hour before dawn.
It's dangerous to be out in the jungle at night without a guide.
What about you?
I have to get back.
I can't be gone for too long.
they'll start to suspect something don't worry I'll keep you updated over the radio that's it my orders are to provide you with information nothing more you look disappointed all right then I'll do something special for you yeah yeah
I'll stand watch until dawn now be a good boy and lie down
What's the matter I don't know you well enough to trust you true how well do you have to know me to trust me?
I don't know if I can trust anybody
The beginning of his his of his eternal trust issues.
Gonna get that?
Battle against everybody.
My little baby, boy, I just wanna hug him.
She's right, Snake.
You should get some sleep.
Stop eavesdropping.
Ugh.
Eavesdropping.
Whenever you save the game and quit, you'll go to sleep.
Sleeping allows you to gain back stamina naturally.
Depending on how long you sleep, you may also recover naturally from sickness and injury.
I like that she's mansplaining.
and sleep.
The best thing to do is just get some sleep.
So do yourself a favor and take a nap.
Doctor's orders, okay?
Yeah, okay.
Eee, bud dropping.
You're like, just stop playing the game.
Take a break.
She's talking to us too.
Miss Little Bratz.
Look, sneaky.
Suspicious.
Good morning, Minto!
I don't know which angle is better, honestly.
What's the matter?
We're surrounded.
I see four of them.
We've got company.
It's the Ocelot unit.
Let's get out of here.
Hurry.
don't forget your gear okay here give me a hand I love this game I love metal
gear we can use this to get to the basement that's not a basement that is a crawl space I'll
get past them on my bike I'll call you later okay I'll keep them busy.
Okay.
Don't get dying on me now.
Huh?
Wait, I want to get in there too.
Wait, how do I get in there?
How do I open it?
Wait, how do I open this?
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
I don't remember.
Make some noise.
Move.
Triangle?
But I think an action...
Wait, is an action button Y or A?
I think they changed it in there.
I don't know.
Wait, they're about to come in?
How did they hear that?
They heard...
Oh, this is messed up.
I wonder if I should go out and just CQC all of them.
Let's try it.
I see them!
Oh, gosh.
Up!
Get up!
For real.
Ow!
Let's see if we can see him.
Where's the other guy?
Oh!
Jeez.
Your guys are down there!
Okay, we got five left.
Oh.
I need a cure.
It kind of worked.
Bandage.
Oink.
Okay, to be fair, though, they also go in the opposite order.
Oh, gunshot.
Oh, sheesh.
Um, bullet.
How do I get the bullet out with the knife?
And then I'm bleeding.
Stop bleeding.
And then I apply the bandage.
I should disinfect it.
It's out of order.
Oh, don't touch the sides.
Use a knife to remove a bullet.
Cool.
All right, come here.
Hmm.
I can't see anything.
Anybody else gonna come in here or...
Can't tell if they do or not.
I don't know if they'll just...
I'm camping.
I'm, like, actually moving my head to distract the area.
Nobody yet.
Uggy.
Let me try opening this again.
Oh, now it gives me the prong.
Of course now it gives it to me.
Wait, what about my stuff?
Oh, I think I need to equip it, huh?
Let's see, backpack.
Aha!
There we go.
When did I get these frogs?
I saw him.
Oh, I have no suppressor on this.
Oops!
Oh god!
Back up!
What's so funny?
How does this affect?
Bleeding.
Bandage.
He'll pass out eventually.
I think I got him at the leg eventually.
That was so funny.
Wait, what if I...
Oh, there he goes.
What's wrong?
Oh.
Wait, maybe I can go out and get his ass.
Are you going to go check on your friend?
Are you gonna look at him?
Nothing here.
Thank you, Robin.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, come here.
Go come here.
Holy.
Oh, I keep pressing Y.
I'm so used to it as an action button.
I see him.
I don't see you!
Oops!
Look it up.
Get up, Snake.
Okay, one more guy.
Where is he
at?
He knows I'm here.
Two can play at that game.
And only one of us has unlimited supply.
Where are you though?
Hello?
I should cure.
I keep getting shot.
Yeah, the Gakko is right there.
Actually, well, I'll shoot him after once all these guys are down.
Where are you?
I just gotta go look for him.
I keep seeing that thing right there and thinking it's a guy.
Hello?
Are you inside?
Stepping so carefully over your bodies?
Oh my gosh.
Hello?
We're gonna spray and pray.
I see
Kero-Tan right there too.
Oh, I see his feet.
Can I get him in through here?
He's dancing or something.
I
think I got his feet.
Oh there.
There we go.
Now we can really get him.
Oh, oops.
Where are you unloading?
Down boy, down.
I know I got your leg.
Really?
Okay.
Oh.
All I had to do was wait two seconds.
It's so funny.
Okay, wait.
My wound is open.
This, in fact, uh...
Suture.
It's a bandage.
Okay, now we're fine.
Now everything's good.
Give me your stuff.
Seabed.
I'll take that.
Alright, now we loot the place.
Why don't I have a suppressor anymore?
Evil, why would you give me a gun without a suppressor?
For a sneaking mission.
Why would you be so cruel to me?
Why would you be so mean?
Oh.
Smoke tree.
So silly.
Ooh, what did you have on you?
A rations.
Wait.
Aren't you the guy I just picked up?
Nope.
What's WPG?
Water.
I'll get water.
I need to get water.
Yes, thank you.
I do need to get water.
Soucher kit.
Perfect.
I keep using those.
White phosphorus grenade.
Yeah!
There we go.
Water, water, water.
Ammo, I'll take that too.
A battery?
Can't remember how many of...
Maybe just two times.
Med?
Pazesamines.
Battery.
Kedotan was here and...
Gakko is upstairs.
One of the rare times we get both of them.
Oh, I think my PC is, like, really dying.
Oh, there's a guy here.
Give me your stuff.
It's hard to tell frame rate stuff.
with not only just streamers but also vtubers because we have extra tech that we use oh he gave us ramen nice I got the locker in Sokolov's just
a few frame drops it's mostly me honestly it's mostly me but yeah So far, it's been...
I've been waiting for this moment.
That's it!
That's the stance!
I don't think so.
That's the...
A female spy?
Lost a lot, you dog.
This bitch is wearing perfume!
stay where you are i've had enough of your judo i see you've got yourself a single action army oh that's right there'll be no accidents this time you call that an accident i love this well it wouldn't have happened if you hadn't been showing off this little freak what did you say it's a nice gun i'll give you that oh god but the engraving gives you no tactical advantage whatsoever oh my god unless you were planning to auction it off as a collector item he's so angry and you're forgetting one more very basic thing you don't have what it takes to kill me we'll see yes
run him over
Yeah!
Six shots.
That thing only carries six shots.
The Makarov carries eight.
You have to get a feel for how many you have left.
Oh gosh.
His brain chemistry is literally and this is a high class weapon.
It's not meant for shooting people.
Six shots.
Wow.
This isn't over yet.
He's still young.
Look at the way he runs.
You'll regret stopping me.
He's still young us a lot.
Damn it.
I've got to get back before he does.
Get out of here!
So cool.
Eva's so cool.
Oh wait, I didn't get to get Gakko.
Will still let me?
Yeah.
Six shots.
What a woman.
Now he can put on the suppressor.
Good!
Actually, before we go onwards...
Water!
Water time.
Water break, everybody.
Water break.
Water break, water break.
I will be...
Or be...
Actually, maybe we can... hold on.
No, not that.
Let's listen.
to somebody talk i'll save and you guys can listen saving the game snake yep yep save him okay snake have you heard of it came from outer space yeah you told me already so this astronomer sees a meteor but it's really an alien spaceship right and the aliens start replacing the townspeople with clones and forcing them to help repair the ship the 3d effects were quite realistic
No, you don't get it.
Precisely because it's realistic.
With the images jumping out of the screen at you.
It makes for a nice escape from reality.
I have to admit it made my eyes tired, but it was really intense.
Unfortunately, they don't make very many of those movies anymore.
When did it come out?
I was still in college, so probably about 10 years ago?
Guess I'm out of luck then.
You know, they're coming out with household versions of video cassette recorders.
One day you'll be able to see old movies anytime you want.
It'll be like having a movie theater in your own home.
It's like if you had a record with movie film etched onto it instead of music.
It'll work the same way.
You're kidding.
No, really.
And someday they might make movies where you control the characters yourself.
Sounds like magic.
It'll happen.
Make sure you stay alive to see it, Snake.
I'm back.
Sorry about that.
I was also looking for my voicemails.
I'm okay give me one second I'm gonna check something on my computer I'm
gonna give it a little more breathing oh it's high oh my computer's high whoa whoa whoa whoa you're okay computer you're okay
okay hot it's really hot in my room oh hello
Let's get back to it.
What did paramedic talk about?
Oh, you're okay, computer.
You're okay.
You got this.
Yeah, I have an external fan on.
Movies, just movies.
Oh, boy.
came from outer space.
Movies in your home?
Pfft.
Never gonna happen.
Impossible.
Ooh.
It'd be cute if there were turtles.
Wow.
Starting to rain.
Stand tall.
Look at that big boy.
Stand a
We gotta go find ourselves a hat.
Red and yellow.
Kill a fellow.
Red and black.
Friend of Jack.
Oh, I can't take off the suppressor once I put it on.
That kind of sucks.
And we are Jack.
Exactly.
It works.
Oh wait, we're getting wet!
We're wet.
Oh no, it distorted his face.
It's like when you use those, you know, did you ever use those filters on Mac computers a long time ago?
That's what it reminds me of.
Okay, I was going to...
It said the crocsuit helps us swim better, no?
He looks so stupid.
Oh my god, it's so good.
Soggy snake.
Oh, whoa.
You're okay, computer.
Look at the...
Look at that frog just glide.
Oof.
Okay.
You're okay, computer.
You got this.
I believe in you.
Oh, that's happening.
Big fish.
Wait, I actually...
I actually don't know how to swim.
Wait, I...
Surface.
Okay, where... if I...
That!
If I were a crawcat, I would be over there.
And if I were a place to...
get up...
Is this a...
I don't want to dive.
No, get on the land.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh!
I didn't see that guy there.
Like, IRL?
No!
I know how to swim.
I know I've got leeches on me, too.
I want to hear them kiss me, though.
This area is absolutely killing me.
Killing my PC, though.
We need to take, we need to eat a little snack.
Oh, speaking of hunger.
But I also heard a little kiss.
I heard a kiss.
Let's get them leeches off of me.
They're like sticking straight out.
I don't think that's how that works.
Oh wait.
How do I...
Oh, cigar.
I'm stupid.
Maria.
That's what they say.
Hello?
Snake, are you there?
Eva?
Did you miss me?
Did you make it without any trouble?
No one saw me.
So you're back with Vulgan?
In a matter of speaking.
What about the boss?
Yeah, she's here too.
Better be careful.
Thanks, I will.
The boss and I get along pretty well, though.
I guess we traders have a lot in common.
The...
Why would anyone want to defect?
The claw.
Betraying your country like that.
I just don't get it.
Are you talking about the boss?
Why'd you do it?
Were you born and raised in America?
Wait, I wonder if there's a new codex for the...
Croc...
Outfit.
With Siggint.
I never even knew there were other countries, other cultures, other ways of thinking.
Until I went to work for the NSA.
Then one day, I'd found I'd lost faith in the things I'd been taking for granted.
What did you see?
What was it that made you want to change sides?
You wouldn't believe me if I told you.
Try me.
I saw the universe.
The universe?
Look how pretty she is.
Not the actual universe.
The universe as the intelligence community sees it.
I realized that the gravity in this universe was holding me back.
That's all.
People and countries are both changed by their environment.
I love this picture of her.
And by the times.
saying.
There's a world of difference between this country and America, but it's only a difference of position, a difference of perspective.
Coming here made me realize something.
Half of what I'd been told was a complete and utter lie.
The other half was a conveniently constructed lie.
Where's the truth then?
It's hidden in the lies.
Hidden in the lies.
Real eyes tell real lies.
I've been trained to make even the most severe falsehood sound like the honest truth.
Weren't you?
No, I believe because I have to.
Even if it is a lie.
That's part of my mission.
I'll have to remember that.
If you need me, give me a call on the radio.
My frequency is 142.52.
Hello?
Are we back?
Back, back, back, back, back.
Hello!
Hi!
One moment.
Everything fell apart.
My mic came undone.
And everything in the world decided to shit on me all at once.
Okay, I'm just gonna have to deal with my mic being broken a little bit.
So OBS crashed.
And then...
And then my, and then the game crashed.
And then my monitor turned off.
I was doing like control alt delete because the game was still going.
I could hear it going with the rain.
And then, and then my monitor, but because my monitor crashed, I, I, I couldn't, I couldn't.
The control alt delete didn't work.
It was.
um let's but right now I'm kind of scared it's saying I hope it saved I hope it saved how did your mic break though well the mic stand broke and my mic started falling that's why actually and I've been trying to fix it the past couple days and It hasn't been cooperating with me.
It should have auto-saved.
Okay.
Let's try it.
Okay, starting the game back up.
Tee-hee.
Setup is in process.
Okay.
Huh?
Nah, my computer is experiencing those problems.
Oh, we have the intro now.
Oh, sorry, we're going to skip it because I want to play Key Plague.
Okay, okay, let's get back in.
What extras do we have now?
We got our scientist.
Low?
Wait, maybe if I just continue.
It should be good.
Okay.
No FSR.
Oh.
I don't remember.
is on yeah I was like I'm pretty sure I had that set
though probably I could turn the resolution down
you know might be worth it hold on how what should I even turn it to though what would we go all the way to Let's see...
But the game was looking so good for me!
One moment.
Ah!
Everything is fucked!
Everybody sucks!
Now I'm small!
Ah!
Okay.
big and then I need you guys okay you're over here why'd you do that?
Why'd you go over there?
alright.
Alright this might help actually.
I probably not might.
I think this will help a lot actually.
I didn't even think about it.
I'll be honest.
I completely forgot to change the resolution.
No it's ruining everything!
No!
I don't know what to do.
Okay, I'm over it.
Let me...
Wait, no.
What did I just press?
Wait, get me back on the gameplays.
Sorry, everything goes by when...
Sorry.
Ah!
Okay.
All right.
Wow, you guys just keep getting bigger and bigger.
Okay.
Alright.
Then?
I'm afraid to...
Wait, where am I?
Okay, there I am.
I'm afraid to click back into the game.
Wait.
Eh?
What?
Oh, that's why.
Oh.
There we go.
I'm flickering like a ghost.
Okay, here we go.
I'm gonna click back into the game.
I'm gonna do it!
I'm going ghost!
Oh, everything was fine.
I'm still lagging bad though.
Okay, now, wait, what if I go back into full screen now?
Oh, it's back at 4K!
You're right, that's why!
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
I'm gonna change it.
Oh,
I'm windowed.
Wait, I did the wrong thing.
I can't full screen it.
I just have to be windowed.
I
could...
It's the only way.
By God, I also...
I was so unprepared for this.
Because I even forgot to turn off wallpaper engine.
I set everything up and I'm just like, okay, this is, this is it.
And I completely, I forgot to do everything.
So my computer, no wonder it was about to crash.
I'm still sleepy from coming home, sorry.
Ha ha, ha, okay.
Anyway, now we should be running out of everything fine.
For what it's worth besides you teleporting flickering a little we see no issues oh i see every everything is flashing at once wait now the screen is so small how am i supposed to see a snake like this but i'm not laggy yay okay we're back everybody we're back in business seizure test actually okay um
I know now now this feels this feels good right okay we are changing into croc
croc sorry I'm just gonna skip through Eva's thing thing wait can I kill this frog oh I heard a I heard a leech come here oh I got him how can he how can the leech get me through?
Wait, I think that thing is poisonous, no?
How can the leech get me through my big old crock suit?
What's over there?
We're gonna go see.
I'm diving.
Just kidding.
No use.
Watch out for the crock.
And why?
Actually, it's so much easier swimming in this game.
I feel like I'm not going every which way.
But Snake is pretty slow.
I'm not going to lie.
Come on, Snake.
Pick up them legs.
Hold on.
I should actually drink the water I got.
It's a troop.
Snake, are you there?
Eva?
Did you miss me?
Did you make it without any trouble?
No one saw me.
So you're back with Vulgan?
of speaking nature skills yeah she's here oh wait this is the one we just saw right careful thanks i will the boss and i get okay i'm gonna fast forward sorry we already listened to this okay jay kai okay this is where we need to go but we want to go up there for the croc hat so that is that is our desired location Ooh,
I just got kissed.
Wait, where am I?
Okay, here we go.
Oh, I just got kissed.
Let's stay away from me.
Soon we'll have to eat.
I will surface.
No!
Be do, be do.
Oh, I did it again.
Okay.
All right.
Come on, Snake.
Pick up them flippers.
Let's have our...
I'm actually starting to get hungry myself.
Let's have ourselves a Siberian in-camp.
Not so great.
The Yabuku-Burloko is also not good, right?
I remember.
He doesn't like it.
Ah, what is this?
What about this, the Otten Frog?
Ah, pretty tasty.
Pretty tasty.
I guess I should get the frog or the leeches too, huh?
Oh, we get a special!
Ew!
We didn't get this one last time.
It's straight on the
nip.
Full of blood.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I've missed one.
Okay.
That's a crock.
You think he'll be able to climb easy with this big old suit on?
Alright, easy does it, easy does it, easy does it, easy does it.
Oh gosh.
Oh, oops.
I have to very awkwardly and very slowly walk back.
I don't know what the button would be, though.
I can't tell if it's A or Y.
I'm going to get these fish.
I'm going to kill them for food.
Oh, come on.
Let me kill the fish.
You think it's A?
Same button to hang.
Okay, okay.
It was so fast.
Oh, let's get rid of this guy real quick.
Okay.
A to hang.
Hang loose.
We're hanging.
We're hanging in there.
Okay.
All right.
We need to let go.
Wait.
We?
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Ah!
Oh, come on.
At least the gator didn't give me.
Brother, why do you keep bothering us?
Oh, come on.
Why is this so difficult?
Wait, I just realized I have the Crock-Hat.
I forgot.
But I want the original.
I feel like we need to get this one too, you know?
Brother.
Brother, what are you doing?
I was pressing A, A, like crazy.
So I don't know.
Might not be me.
Might be the fault of the game.
Could never be me.
Uh oh, I'm kind of hungry.
We did it.
We did it, Reddit.
Will I make it?
Please say yes.
And just because my depth perception is really bad.
Croc cap.
The original, baby!
The original.
This might help, actually.
Oh, wait.
Under item, probably.
This might help us with getting through this next part.
Let's see.
Ye-ho!
Wait, I think we have both in my inventory, too.
Nope.
Just the one.
Okay.
Let's chow down.
on something.
A reticulated python.
Oh, we get the viewer.
Are you eating it or just spitting it out?
I want some more.
Let's see how so...
Oh, wait.
Wrong thing.
Zero.
Look at me.
it looks like you've got rid of all the ocelots yeah now proceed with the rescue of sokolov according to eva you should start by going to the crevice to the north can we trust her what's that eva's with the kgb isn't she can i really believe how many snacks how do i know she won't actually have to make food for me there are no guarantees in espionage snake only calculated guesses at this point in time the kgb stands nothing to gain by stabbing us in the back I'm saying the chance that she'll betray you is low.
Of course, we checked the route she gave you against our own data.
It looks like a pretty solid infiltration route.
It makes good use of weak spots in the enemy's defenses.
You shouldn't have any problems.
Follow the route Eva showed you and proceed with the mission.
Roger.
First, enter the cave through the crevice.
Eva said it was to the north.
So head that way.
You got some instant noodles, huh?
Instant noodles.
Uh-huh.
It was invented in Japan just recently.
Add some hot water and it's ready to eat.
It's cheap and can be stored for a long time.
And besides, it's delicious.
It's like a miracle food.
Wow.
It's yummy.
Which?
I want some ramen.
Are you going to eat that?
I was planning on it, yeah.
No, all right.
Is there some reason I shouldn't?
No, that's not what I meant.
Then what did you mean?
I was just going to say that if you going to eat it you should bring it back to me i've always wanted to try some whatever
let's see i think sigan's gonna tell us all about other weapons though i think hey snake remember back at the abandoned factory we have a couple codex to get through before we get the the croc i've never heard of a customization like that before why the grip to fit it with a knife A knife?
You gonna keep the knife and the gun both at the ready?
What do you have?
A knife.
Why would you wanna do that?
Sometimes a knife works better in close proximity encounters.
So I equip both at the same time.
Okay, I might go heat up my food while I'm sorry.
I keep taking breaks.
Badass.
So there's that.
CQC.
Okay, hold on.
So I'm gonna put on zero.
And then, unless it's about the crocsuit.
That swamp seems pretty deep.
It's probably deep enough to dive under and swim around press the crouch button when you're swimming on the surface to dive underwater the controls when you're underwater differ somewhat from when you're on land the movement stick controls the direction you will get hungry simply move the movement stick to move in that direction simply move the movement press the action button repeatedly to swim faster this is useful when you're in a hurry you can also press the evade button to surface in an emergency if you want to change the direction you're facing because i was using my mouse that's crazy okay zero look at my crocsuit snake you'll be helpless if a crocodile attacks you in the water they won't you can't see behind you when you're swimming actually i don't think they do because i'm in that crocsuit keep an eye on your six also by using your sensors you should be able to detect crocodiles before they get too close look at it look at it major zero
How does it look?
It looks cool.
Yeah.
It looks cool on you.
It does.
Yeah.
I don't think cool is the right word.
It does.
Why?
What's wrong with it?
What's wrong?
Don't you think it looks silly?
Doesn't it make you laugh?
Aren't you going to ask me what the hell I was thinking?
No.
Oh.
I think it really does look good.
It reminds me of the alligator people.
Oh, the... what?
alligator people he's like yeah you've never heard of it no oh well you should see it sometime it's about this guy who gets hurt in a car accident and tries to heal his wounds by injecting himself with a crocodile serum but then his head turns into a crocodile head you look just like sounds like me that's awesome right oh never mind i suppose you might be able to disguise yourself as a crocodile by wearing that cap and sticking your head out of the water Yeah!
Sigint, look at my hat.
Sounds like the Cobra Unit's members' names came from the specific emotions they each carry into battle.
Emotions?
Lord of Man, lore.
For unbearable torment, the pain.
The pain.
For true oblivion, the end.
For infinite rage, the fury.
For absolute terror, the fear.
And for unsurpassed bliss, the joy.
the joy it's another name for the boss because of the joy she feels in battle I suppose during the war she had a partner named the sorrow sorrow and joy they say there couldn't have been a more perfect pair
man wait but second look at my hat snake you said Eva said her mouser was a type 17 right yeah what about it that model was produced in the 1920s and a weapons lab in the Shang-Zhi province in China.
The cartridge part sticks out lower than the original to accommodate 45 caliber rounds.
The barrel and chamber are a little bit thicker too.
But most telling of all, it's got Chinese characters engraved on both sides of the frame like you saw.
And that firing stance, Eva, was talking about when you hold the gun horizontally.
That's a trademark of the Chinese.
Way, way, way.
When you're firing in full auto mode, the muzzle jump effect gives you a horizontal strafing motion.
they say it's especially deadly in indoor and close-range mop-up actions the Japanese called it bandit shooting and used to dread it and it makes you wonder where she learned to shoot like that I love a woman that knows how to shoot you know that army motorcycle that Eva was riding that's a replica of a German yeah after World War two the Soviets confiscated an entire assembly line from a German motorcycle factory machines and all and then they took it back with them and started producing replicas exactly originally that motorcycle was designed to be used with the sidecar attached that means it's got enough power to drag a 200 plus pound sidecar around so that's how she could pull off all those crazy stunts I was trying to move the window so I could see how long I've been streaming now the OBS is reset let's see one more the Davy Crockett's that the boss took with her when she defected are mortars that fire nuclear warheads.
They're named after Davy Crockett, the hero who died defending the Alamo in the Texan War of Independence.
Remember the Alamo.
That's right.
The warheads are equivalent to between 10 and 20 tons of TNT.
Every building within 150 yards of the Hypo Center is completely obliterated.
But the warheads the boss had with her were some kind of experimental super bomb.
That's crazy.
So they're actually even more powerful than that.
I don't even want to think about what happened if she used it again Snake, you know what you have to do.
Yeah, I know
Makes me so sad
Makes me so sad Oh, come on.
I was in the water for two seconds You stinking leech at least these guys Don't take...
Wait a second.
Wait.
Oh, I thought I had something on my feet.
Um, they don't take supplies or anything.
Crawling like I'm a crocodile.
I'm a crocodile.
Hope NGS Con was fun for you.
It was!
I love hearing the the what's it called of the of the suit you hear it
I think they'll be afraid of me if I'm a crocodile oh you see that you see that right there okay oh there's one over there wait can I crawl up to it and grab it
Can I grab that?
Go eat.
I realize the food that I have is, like, kind of messy at my computer desk, so...
I don't think I could grab it.
Or can I...
Go...
You can?
It didn't prompt me.
Unless there's no prompt.
Alright, Snake.
Turn around.
Let's try this guy.
Oh.
I didn't know if they updated it.
Okay, never mind.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
So I'm just gonna be a crocodile this entire time, I think.
I think it would make this part a whole lot easier.
I don't like this area.
Snake!
Snake, what were you doing?
What were you thinking?
Okay.
The dog hasn't even noticed me.
Is it because I'm a alligator?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna be a crock.
How did he hear that?
Did the suppressor not work?
Or maybe because of the dog yield.
He's just asleep.
I'm gonna crack it down.
Wait.
I think I need to go the other way, huh?
Wait, can I go through here?
No.
The dogs wake up faster, too, though.
Wait, I can't?
I gotta roll through it.
Oh, like, on the tree branch?
Was it that one?
I know there was one that you have to take the tree branch through it.
Um.
I'm like being so silly.
No, I don't think this is a tree branch one.
There's a hole.
Where do you guys see that?
I think.
Oh, right there!
Okay.
I wonder if I can get this guy.
Let's try.
Okay.
The drop off, it's kind of crazy.
So, three, two, one.
I want him to go to sleep before I try.
There's nothing here.
Okay, nerd.
Wow, this is a great shot.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Oh, there's two guys.
Uh...
Am I hitting the fence?
Oh!
Oh, nope.
I'm definitely hitting him.
And we're down.
Where'd that other guy go?
I'm not trying for a no-kill run.
It's just happening um...
Without me trying, I suppose you would say.
Where'd that guy go?
Where am I?
Thanks for the tutorial on the map.
He's wearing a crock suit too.
He said, let me slip into something more comfortable.
I kind of want to see the reaction though.
But we did so well in this area.
Let's just go to the next part.
We can see people's reactions.
Look at him go.
All crack run.
Oh, let's not stand up because we're a crocodile and they don't do that.
Oh, it's this area.
I forgot about this area.
Okay, hold on.
I want to see them react to the croc.
Hold on.
I'm going to say...
Save.
Do you want to save?
Yes.
Hey, Snake.
Maybe I should go here at my foot now.
Nah.
It's about this expedition that goes to the planet Altair IV in an ultra-fast spaceship.
When they arrive, they meet the survivor of the last expedition.
But I want to see what his reaction is to my full crocodile outfit.
Dr. Morbius was exploring the planet along with his daughter Altaira and the versatile Robbie the Robot.
Robbie the Robot.
Ignoring the doctor's warnings, the expedition team is suddenly attacked by an invisible creature called the monster from the id.
The special effects they use for the science stuff were really neat.
I wish I had a robot like Robbie that could make anything I wanted it to.
I'm more interested in that invisible monster.
If I were invisible, I wouldn't have to bother hiding or wearing camouflage.
Maybe someday you'll be able to turn invisible.
Invisible.
Yeah, that'll be the day.
Wow.
Did I think they're just, are they just gonna think that a crocodile is walking in on their base?
That'd be so funny.
Hold on.
Come here.
Please come here.
I think I saw something.
You might have heard my tummy.
You see a crocodile?
Wait.
I want him to come look at me.
I'm a crocodile.
Hey.
Hey, come check me out.
Come check me out.
Who's that?
What?
No!
No way you could do!
Please respond.
Oh my god.
I thought they would be so scared of me.
Screw this.
It's time to change.
Didn't do that.
You know, I just realized I haven't had, like, rashes equipped or anything.
Oh, I'm gonna die for real.
I think I think I'm gonna die.
Ow!
I think I'm gonna die.
Get me out of here.
If I die, it's okay.
Ow!
Um, can you- Oh, I don't have CQC.
That's why- Oh, my bad.
I didn't mean to press that.
But, well, uh, I kind of want to start over.
I just wanted to experiment with the crack.
Now I'm more sad.
Ow!
Hold on, I'm too sad.
I don't care about you attacking me.
My crock suit failed me.
I'm too sad.
Crocodile.
They didn't even do that.
I'm so sad.
No, what's the point?
What's the stinking point?
Why are all of these worse than the croc suit?
Wait.
Oops.
Are these really all worse than the croc suit?
Dangy.
There was a guy who came out.
Oh, I see him now.
I wonder if I can get him.
Good enough.
Still hit.
Just my imagination.
Okay, I can't see you because of the croc.
The croc stays on.
Absolutely.
Oops.
Ah!
What am I...
How am I missing?
Okay!
Really sounded like me right now, Snake.
Eat.
Hey, this worked.
I can feed them the poison the poison frog wait hold on let's put that in our backpack poison frog in our backpack we can set we can throw that over to them and they'll be like oh oh he's stupid he's an idiot dummy dumb
oh oh hello oh i did get him i can't tell the sounds are so strange now it's hard for me to tell i'll be honest everything sounds so different you know so i'm like do i have regular grenades i have to yeah i think i do
usually there's a hit noise it is but it's like a instead actually crocsuit kind of op
I'm so, I'm so disguised.
Let's blow up some stuff.
Let's blow up.
Severe burns.
I'll commit war crimes.
Wait, let's put all of the grenades.
Because I can have unlimited.
Yeah, I won't forget the other stuff too.
Okay, let's see.
How does this work?
Ready?
L-T-R-T, okay.
Crawl over to which...
Wait.
Claymores are...
I'm stupid.
That's not...
We'll do the grenades.
I don't know.
Claymores...
I was thinking of C4.
Okay.
Um.
You.
Where does that, where do I, should I blow it up?
Did that work?
HQ.
This is HQ.
Patrol here.
We're under fire.
Enemy position unknown.
Commencing alert status.
Acknowledged.
Sending reinforcements.
Use extra caution.
What did you...
Wait, what did I just pick up?
Shut up.
You guys were bothering me.
Guess nothing new.
I don't even think it worked.
Ah.
Why don't they give me...
Yeah, it worked to alert them.
Everything is bad.
You don't think they'll come in here, right?
Need C4.
Oh, wait.
I think you get this.
I think you get it in that other little hut, maybe.
You think they can see my hat from...
Oh, wait.
It doesn't...
Oh, it does clip.
You think they saw that?
That would be insane.
I kind of messed up, guys.
I messed up.
I done goofed.
I did a little whoopsie.
Do you think I can make it?
Is he?
I hear footsteps.
Oh, wait.
HQ, please respond.
This is HQ.
Patrol here.
Enemy sighted, commencing attack.
Close the door.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, get up.
Get up, Snake.
Killing your comrades.
There's so many men here.
Wow.
There's a whole lot of guys in here.
Ah, why?
Why are you hurting?
Look at the cross.
Look at it, it's so funny.
Okay, I'll get it after.
Oh, that's where you are.
I see one.
I hear two, I think.
Oh, the alert's going down.
They're stupid.
They don't know what's going on.
Damn.
Are we getting away with this for real?
Oh, there's that guy right there.
HQ.
This is HQ.
Control here.
There he goes.
We lost sight of the intruder going into high alert.
Let's put back our crocsuit.
The enemy is still nearby.
Pursue and engage him.
No.
They're gonna come from this way, don't they?
Actually, this is the way I need to go, right?
Oh, that didn't mean to do that.
Is it this way?
No, this is the other little hut.
I'm lost in the south, thank you.
I should have never tried to blow up your helicopter.
I should have never tried.
for my arrogance.
Oh, I should cure.
I'm stupid.
My wound is open.
Disinfect.
Oh, easy.
Okay, cool.
It was funny, though.
Here we go.
On the road again.
Wait.
Is this whole cutscene gonna be...
Wait a second.
Wait, is this whole thing...
Oh, no.
Oh no!
No!
I want to put on the Crockett.
Ah, you're here at last.
Looks like the boss's info was right.
Twice now you've made me taste for the defeat.
Yes, sir!
Oh my gosh, our first boss, you guys.
I hate to disappoint the Cobras, but you're mine now.
Oh.
Oh, all of you, leave us.
Oh, Ocelots are such prideful creatures.
The way it keeps chopping.
It's just you and me.
Every time it cuts the scene, Ocelots are proud creatures.
Yeah!
They prefer to hunt alone.
Twelve shots.
Yes, keep going, King!
Yes!
This time I've got 12 shots.
Oh, you are such a frightening creature.
Draw!
Okay, one moment, please.
Let me fix my outfit.
Well, we really don't need it, but, you know.
What am I using?
Okay, oh, interesting.
It shows you the number of bullets he has up there and his health.
We shall...
I wish I could take my suppressor off.
Because I don't want to...
I don't want to use it all up.
You know?
Yeah, that's...
Oh, no, I'm not.
I meant the location, sorry.
The location of the...
of the... his...
HP.
If I do...
I try it, wait, it does say attach... Oh!
Oh my gosh, I'm blind.
I was like, oh, it doesn't say it, no!
Oh, it does, okay.
Look at the way he runs.
And then I'm gonna switch to... No, not that.
I'm gonna switch to this, sorry.
I'm so brain dead from this weekend.
Look at him go.
No!
Don't shoot me!
Thank you.
Wait.
Ow!
Ouch, ow, ow, ow!
The thrill.
Look at him!
Please!
Let me have him, please!
Oh my god.
It's exhilarating!
Damn.
Excellent.
Getting him?
Oh, I think my drop-off is too bad.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Just like camping behind this little rock.
Oh, that's a goat.
Where are you?
Where'd you go?
I'm trying to find- I want to watch you!
I want to watch you reload!
Where are you?
Where?
Oh.
Ah.
Oh, there you are.
Yeah?
Here.
Please don't, please don't.
I'm gonna cure.
You see me press B all the time because it used to be, it was circle, you know.
So I always, I'm always pressing back because I'm so used to it.
Disinfect.
And then my bandage.
Oh, suture.
Oh, not the suture.
Ah, I used it.
What was it?
Oh, the bleeding.
There we go.
There probably is a way to remap, but I...
I don't... It's... You know, it's okay.
Damn.
I almost had him.
Okay, let's reload.
Reload.
where are you doing that from oh oh there's some they do give me ammo oh shoot they got him tushay he loves me he's so in love with me
how did I miss oh
never just kidding what was I looking at I thought one more I'm silly oh he ouch he's so fast
What a jerk!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh!
That was so romantic!
Oh my god!
Wow, wow!
I'm getting hungry.
Let's eat our reticulated python.
That was so romantic!
We shot each other at the same time!
Wow!
Love that.
I'm doing this with the Crock-Cat the whole time.
Oh
my god, he's doing it at double speed.
Oh my god.
Jeez.
It's so funny.
Where are you?
Oh.
Got his ass.
He was so exhilarated.
Damn it.
He found us.
No!
Huh?
Uh oh.
The bees!
Wait, I want to see what he looks like.
Eww!
Oh, nasty!
Now get out of here all this lot, unit.
If he can.
You were lucky.
We'll meet again.
Oh, yeah, we will.
Amazing.
Thank you.
Woo!
I
love a good snake yell.
It really comes from the throat, you know.
I got animals.
Oh, wait.
Let's, uh...
Attach.
Our...
I can't
see anything.
Look at all them crabs!
So many.
Oh gosh, I can't see... I can't see anything.
It's like Ocelot was showing Snake is cool twirly, but...
Crab battle, yeah.
Where did I come from?
Okay, over here.
I always do the wrong one.
Help!
Snake, are you okay?
Snake!
Major.
Snake.
Are you all right?
You're not hurt?
No.
That was a hell of a drop, but I'm fine.
Looks like there's no way back up, though.
You were just ordered right during stream.
Thanks for ordering.
Well, anyway, it's good to hear you're not injured.
Even you?
Your profile, Victor?
But getting into that cave was.
proceed further into the cave the cave seems to be structured like a maze but there's an exit somewhere find a way out of the cave and head for the aqueduct okay wait
snake are you all right yeah just barely what the hell were all those hornets most likely that was the pain one of the cobras i figured as much are they tracking me i don't know the cobras only take orders from the Even Volgin knows what they're really up to.
So I don't know anything about them either.
No kidding.
I'll try and dig up as much as I can about them.
You just focus on moving ahead.
Go to the end of the cave and you'll come out in an aqueduct overgrown with mangroves.
This leads to the Pony Zovier Swamp.
Pony Zovier Swamp.
Be careful.
That cave...
Is pitch dark inside.
Yeah.
Good.
I did remember to tell you then.
If it's completely dark and you need a light, try using a torch i heard there's some emergency torches stored somewhere in that cave torches got it so where are they yeah huh where are the torches how should i know go find them yourself eva dark wait i want to see the tip wait did i press the wrong one which one is it this is this tip view tip oh look at that the dark cave is great they reduce visibility wait verse is also on Sola leaves himself open to attack while he's reloading.
Keep an eye on his remaining ammo under the life gate.
Oh, wow.
Oh, how cute!
These are so...
Shake.
Oh, look at him.
Gakko.
Kero-tan.
Store.
Oh.
Okay.
I can't see anything.
Thank you.
I don't know.
I don't have anything other than thermal, right?
I didn't grab a night vision.
I remember.
Can't freaking see.
I can't see anything.
Can your eyes adjust to the darkness in this one?
That's a good question.
Let's see, what else do I have in my backpack?
Um, which is, I mean, I do have live medicine, how many?
one.
Um.
Nothing.
Where even were the...
Where even are the night vision?
Oh, wait.
There's our cigar.
Let's try that.
Does that give any light?
Oh, the tiniest bit.
Okay.
Oh, I think actually our eyes are adjusting.
I can see so much better now.
Like, actually.
yeah yeah yeah our eyes are definitely adjusting that's cool just enough yeah neat oh it looks so good
yeah nice
can i get up here or is this one of those ledges that snake can't lift his arms to oh i stand corrected we'll find them wow Wow!
Wait!
AK-47.
Holy cow.
They glow so nice in this game!
Wow!
They're like actually glowing.
Crab battling.
Come on.
It's just one little crab.
You crab.
Come on.
I'll get you.
I got him good.
That took forever.
Let's see.
I saw a hole over there.
There's a hole there.
Is that something at the bottom of the water?
I see stuff.
And I, yeah, I will.
do the call about the mushrooms because I like that one.
I think it's funny.
Oh!
Yeah,
I love the mushroom call.
Dive, snake.
Keep pressing B.
I'm swimming, I'm swimming, I'm swimming, I'm swimming, I'm swimming, I'm swimming, I'm swimming.
Swimming so fast.
Faster than anyone has ever gone before.
I would like to find...
The torches, though, for real.
Oh!
Look at that.
I'm fast.
We're gonna avoid drowning.
Don't worry.
I'm so fast.
Yay!
You two?
Everybody's got the...
The Ocelot profile picture.
There should be a... Oh, wrong button.
There should be a mountain.
Yes.
What?
I think... Wait, I do see that there's stuff over here in this.
We managed to avoid drowning.
why is it suddenly so bright in here huh there it is oh my gosh wow wow i can see everything now
i don't think we i'll be honest i did put up the brightness a teeny tiny bit but i don't even think we need the torches it's so i i put it up like and when i say teeny tiny bit i meant like a watch so that
so that um it wouldn't be so dark on stream for you guys
Gakko oh Gakko found that's so cute um there was some I don't want to crawl all the way back through but Gakko Gakko Wait, I think this is our torches.
Nope.
These are dead people.
And a little red.
Little, little red.
Little red.
Bug juice.
What are the torches?
No, wait.
I didn't.
Wait.
Huh?
Oh, man.
I'm not...
Oh.
It took away my light!
Let's go back.
Oh no!
Our eyes need to adjust again!
Wait.
Am I going?
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, while our eyes adjust, I'm going to go heat up some food.
I will be right back.
BRB, all I have to do is throw it in the microwave, so it's not going to take long.
I'm not going to, like, wait for it to cook.
Okay, hopefully that doesn't burn down the cafe.
Okay, we can see again.
Let's see.
Where are you?
And I'm...
No!
I was...
Oh, Rachel.
I didn't mean to do that.
Okay, we'll just use the map.
Oh, oh.
On the wall, Snake.
Just hug the walls.
Usually I am okay with direction.
Serum.
I
have no night vision.
Oh my god, I can't see anything.
Wait, I'm at his crotch.
I didn't mean to.
I'm sorry.
I did a banter.
A flashbang grenade.
Let's try it.
Oh, I took it out.
Because we were getting flashbang.
Am I in?
in the wall?
Yeah.
Just hug the wall, Snake.
Snake, I can't see anything.
Oh, no, Snake, we're getting hungry.
Wait.
Is this where I came from?
Yes.
Ah!
Oh, yeah, my cigar.
I forgot that we actually had something that worked a little bit.
Oh, wrong.
Wrong way.
This way.
Works the tiniest amount.
Ah!
Okay, never mind.
Everything is bad.
I just want to have a torch.
Okay, where are we?
Okay, that's where we crawled through.
I got souvenirs I'll cherish forever.
Favorite thing I got was Ocelot.
Um...
Oh wait, I think this is it.
This is it.
No!
I could have sworn it was this here Be do I could have sworn it was with some dead body somewhere
It's underwater flow Let's get this codex
I see you have a calorie mate Calorie mate The thing you're holding now I kind of want a calorie block that looks like a cookie try it it's pretty good it's pretty good okay but what is this thing never seen anything like it calorie made is an energy supplement that contains all the proteins lipids vitamins carbohydrates and minerals here comes the ads skip a skip a it's a well-balanced food because of that it's just perfect for giving your body the nutrition it needs in combat it sounds like a space-age food real astronaut food is not very good but that should taste fine yeah you guys like I can't balance out all this jungle food I'm eating.
It's easy and quick to eat, so it's perfect when you're running late for an important mission in the morning.
Don't you have a box?
I think I have several.
Really?
Aren't you always keeping people waiting?
Oh!
Furthermore, one of Calorie Mate's biggest advantages is that they are all exactly the same portion size.
So no matter how you eat it, you always get the same nutrients flavor in calories.
A lot of people have never had it.
Each Calorie Mate has a set number of calories, so it's easy to keep track of your calorie intake it's not bad all of the geisha girls in japan use calorie mate for watching their calories i see you seem to know a lot about japan don't you yes i love japan yes i love japan hangs up so funny okay is this a dead end or does it didn't look like it on the map.
Snake, I can't see.
Snake.
Wait, I can see now.
Refuses to elaborate.
Oh, I guess it is a dead end.
It looks kind of not like a dead end, but yeah.
It looks like there's just a tiny little hole there.
You can eat after you're done with work, Snake.
Is it under this waterfall?
Which dead body is the...
Is the torch with?
It's like, it's under a...
It's by a dead body for sure.
Do you think those are the same crabs that ate Amelia Earhart?
Let's try the...
Wait.
Let's try the mangrove crab.
I don't think...
I remember this not being tasty either.
Pretty tasty.
I was completely wrong.
I said tasty.
I was like, it's not so tasty.
And then he says pretty tasty.
The opposite.
Oh, it's under.
Weapon.
I'm going to become big sorrow.
Yay!
Paramedic doesn't like it.
Smells like cats.
Cat pee.
Ew.
Cat pee is a terrible smell.
So that's kind of valid.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Big Saru the goat.
It's this guy named Big Saru on YouTube and Twitter and he wears the crock hat and bears the torch and causes all sorts of mischief.
I've used this loadout to beat the boss in the old version.
Oh wait, how do I get back up there?
Oh, I have to crawl, that's right.
Get that frog.
He's like a god gamer, especially with these games.
He knows, like, how the AI work to a T.
What is this game?
Never heard of it.
It's this brand new game that came out today.
Metal Gear Solid 3 Delta.
Metal Gear Delta 3.
Metal Solid.
Solid Gear.
Solid Man Gear.
Delta 1.
What?
There's a map?
Maybe it just tells me the map thing.
With my prompt at the beginning.
I don't remember.
This up is for...
Nothing.
Ouch!
Ow!
Oh, the bat!
The bat!
I'm scared!
Ow, my god.
Still more?
We're eating good tonight.
What's that?
Okay.
Wait a second.
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Did I go through everything?
Why does it feel so much smaller than I remember?
I feel like the cave used to be...
The cave system was, like, humongous.
With so many crawly places.
Did I just miss a bunch?
Hmm.
Metal 3, Solid Gear Eater, Delta Snake.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like it was so much bigger.
I missed Carotan, yeah.
Hmm.
But what did I, where did I miss stuff?
Oh, wait.
Up here.
Wait, wait.
I can't tell.
tell if that's just no we definitely miss stuff there okay yeah up there we miss things oh cute it tells us what the next map is too in the jungle let's go let's go i know there's more like i oh where are the bats coming from the bats hate the okay if i go
Down and around.
Whoa, fancy.
Yes, okay.
I don't think there's anything...
Oh, wait.
I see a tiny hole.
Hold on.
Let's go back in here.
I see a tiny, tiny part of the map that seems...
Wait, where am I?
I'm getting all confused.
Wait, how did I end up in here?
I'm getting all turned around.
Wait, where?
Ugh, I don't like the toll.
Wait!
Okay, you know what?
I'm already here.
I'm getting all turned around.
I can't see anything.
Ugh!
Okay, here is...
Yes.
Okay, this is...
Then we'll go back to the waterfall and explore that one area.
Oh, that's right!
I don't think I could.
Let's try it.
No, I know what I'm doing.
You guys don't know what...
You guys are not reading my mind, and you don't know what I'm doing.
And you're saying, you have to do this, but I have another plan.
You're not reading my mind, and how dare you not do that?
How dare you not read my mind and know exactly what I'm trying to do?
okay here we go can i climb this no all right but this is this is this is that part okay okay okay and then i see that tiny little hole in the waterfall room okay i'll go back i just wanted to see what this was since i was getting already confused
all right come on snake Pick it up.
I'm reading your mind.
There are some wild thoughts in there.
Yeah, that's one of those ledges.
That's one of those ledges that...
Oh my god, you're already tired again, Snake.
I mean, hungry.
One of those ledges that he can't lift his arms for.
It's so lost in here.
Play this dang game a million times.
This leads to...
Okay.
We'll just go.
He's a growing boy.
He is indeed.
Sounds like my tummy right now.
I don't know how far I'll go in the game.
We'll see.
But the little hole I want to go through It was not quite...
It's down there, I believe.
Yeah, right there.
I think.
Yes.
There we go.
I was like, I know this cave is bigger.
I know it is!
And now, okay, now we're...
Okay, okay, okay.
But where is Kerotan?
I like the Aw, we're out
I'm like kind of jet lagged I'm sorry you're getting sleepy Oh, I came right Oh, yeah Okay Where are we Don't you dare Don't you touch me Don't touch me freak I'm gonna have nightmares I'm gonna have nightmares you can get jet lag going east coast west coast of the United States still a three-hour time difference and I had a busy busy weekend
oh my
god oh oh you guys we did it we finally got the night vision goggles we did it we got the night vision you know what this is is this faster i guess maybe i like watching the froggy swim
maybe this is stupid to do without eating first
oh gosh okay
let's eat eat Ah, not too bad.
Not too bad.
This one is not good.
The Russian rations?
Nasty.
Disgusting.
Beat the poison frog.
We gotta make snake throw up.
We gotta do that.
My man's gotta be puking his guts out.
Blah.
Oh, wait.
Uh.
Okay, now we can go fight.
How long am I playing today?
Until I feel tired.
Which I am, but I'm really tired of playing.
Until I don't want to anymore.
Okay, before we fight, though, let's go in here.
And do Kodak.
oh i see you've caught yourself a tyrant i think you're a west coast streamer the tyrant is native to taiwan and southern china it's quite vicious and carries a potent neurotoxin in its fangs maybe i should eat before no if it bites you go it will be my reward for defeating the pain the cure option to inject yourself with serum sounds interesting don't ask me huh the guide doesn't say if you absolutely have to know then you'll just have to try it and see I didn't say anything what he's wearing the croc at I just saw it maybe I'll talk to you later snake I love it paramedic wait what about these glow shrooms I see you've captured a poison dart frog the poison dart frog is native to the tropical rainforest of Central and South America they normally grow between two and five centimeters in length but for some reason the ones in that area seem to be much bigger than that I think he wears it in the original potent neurotoxin called familiotoxin.
Familiotoxin.
Long ago, people used the poison to coat their arrows for hunting.
Watch out because if you eat one, you'll get food poisoning.
Rupro.
Okay, but...
I see you've caught a vampire bat.
The vampire bat bites its victims and sucks their blood.
Why does it have to be vampires?
Speaking of bats, just save it.
Huh?
I know you're going to talk about vampire movies.
Attack of the Vampire Donuts or Dracula versus the Space hippos or something like that actually I was going to say that bats are known to use supersonic waves to sense their surroundings oh bats use supersonic waves to sense their surroundings okay you just said that by blasting them with a special kind of sound wave alternatively you could try gripping a torch and waving it around with the CQC yeah I've been doing that as for taste I suppose there's no reason you couldn't eat them hmm snake do you hate vampire movies just now you sounded like you really hated them i did yeah oh well no one really likes them do they some people do i like you nimmy nightmare they're fascinating you know like the movie drac don't say it why not just don't are you afraid what you're afraid of vampires aren't you don't be ridiculous but listen there are no such things as vampires They're just a stupid,
made-up legend.
And if they do seem real sometimes...
Let me mention.
Well, sure.
You think I'd be afraid of something like that?
No.
Exactly.
Right.
I'm not afraid of vampires.
Uh-huh.
It's just that...
Whenever somebody starts talking about vampires, I end up dreaming about them that night.
Yeah!
And I don't need that right now.
That's all.
Okay.
I see you found some Russian glow caps.
The Russian glow cap is a kind of luminescent fungus, a mushroom that glows in the dark.
Why would a mushroom glow in the dark?
It's bioluminescent, just like a firefly.
It uses the so-called Luciferin-Luciferase reaction.
To put it simply, Luciferin reacts with Luciferase in the presence of magnesium 2 plus ions, breaking it down into oxy-Luciferin and carbon dioxide.
The carbonyl groups and the oxaluciferin are initially in a neutral excited state.
When they return to their base state, they give off light.
Did you get all that?
Not really.
Oh, he's so dumb.
By the way, does that mushroom recharge your batteries when you eat it?
Huh?
I mean, it seems like if you ate a glowing mushroom, it might recharge your batteries or something.
Snake, your batteries are organic batteries.
They produce electricity by utilizing the potential difference between cells.
Organic batteries are known for their highly efficient energy conversion, but they still rely on chemical reactions between proteins and enzymes to...
So you're saying they'll get recharged.
Believe what you want.
Okay, now let's eat one.
Hmm.
Battery recharged!
Were these ones bad?
not eaten yet but said to be edible in a pinch
sick sick okay now let's call her again oh wrong thing
paramedic what's up you were right about what I ate a Russian glow cap and it charged up my batteries what's wrong I that's That's great.
Um, Snake, can you excuse me for a second?
Did you just hear that?
Yeah.
There's no way eating a bioluminescent mushroom would cause your batteries to recharge.
What do you think it means?
Beats me.
Maybe it's all in his mind.
You mean like a placebo effect?
Why not?
You've seen how gullible he is.
Don't say that.
Should we let him keep believing it?
Sounds good to me.
Snake, I'm back.
Yes, the Russian gold cap is a glowing mushroom.
So it'll recharge your batteries when you eat it.
He's so sweet.
Oh, Snake.
Okay.
Shall we go?
Wait, what's over here?
Did I go this way before?
but no I didn't I missed this part we got oh with a shotgun hello wait leave me alone you know what I'm just gonna go I'm just gonna leave what's in over here wait oh gosh okay remember how I was just like I remember this cave being way bigger.
I knew what I was talking about.
We got a snow uniform.
I was worried you'd miss the shotgun.
Well, if I'm doing mostly non-lethal anyway, it would be nice to have like as an option.
Well, even with the other bosses, with the bosses I still like to do non-lethal.
Holy longest cave ever.
What is this?
Oh, I think I know where we are.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
That was just a big old circle.
I see Kerala-Tan up there.
Okie dokie!
Earlier, Snake said, I believe because I have to for the mission.
I am thinking his goal ability is actually on purpose by him.
Miss Minky beating up Grimlock?
No, you didn't!
In fact, let's change.
Oh, wait.
I'm already wearing my grenades.
I feel like this fight will be so much easier when I can see where I'm throwing the grenades, so...
Let's try it, baby!
What grenades do I have?
Oh, wait, though.
But if I'm trying non-lethal, I guess I won't need grenades, huh?
Hmm.
Stun Grenades, y'all.
I've caught you at last.
We are the sons of the boss.
I am the pain.
Okay, he looks better here than he did before.
I will guide you to a world of anger.
absolute like sentai villain
wait i think i forgot to wait oh wrong line no not go i think i forgot to switch out we'll do the stun grenades instead of the smoke grenades
yeah nope time be gone Uh, we're going on food.
Okay.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, dive!
Dive, dive, dive, dive!
I can hear him saying it.
What are you doing?
Wait.
Oh, come on!
Wait, what are you doing?
Oh, dive, dive, dive!
My aim is bad.
I like that we can reload and switch.
I just learned that as a feature.
He's totally vibing.
Oh, can I dive?
There we go.
Oop!
Is that following me?
Wait, I'm trying to leave.
Oh wait.
It's not highlighting him.
hell.
Oh, wait.
I can't...
Oh, I think I was in a bad spot.
Dang it!
Oh, there we go.
Uh, hello?
Hello?
No!
Not Tommy gun!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, luckily we have infinite.
Grenades.
Did you see me?
Oh, ah, ah, ah.
Wait, did it not?
Oh, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Wait.
Oh, I think you shot it back at me.
Now you go.
Oh, ah, ah, ah, ah.
There's like an auto aim.
Did you see that?
Hello?
Can I turn that off?
Wait, sorry.
I think I noticed it earlier and thought it was like a...
I thought something happened, but...
Yeah, the grenade arcline is a big improvement.
Under controls, maybe.
Oh, aim assist on!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I don't want it to be like that.
That's too easy.
Okay.
Okay, uh...
Oh, that would be first!
Oh.
Boom.
No!
No, what the heck?
I don't know if the sun grenade is even doing much, to be honest.
Oh, come on.
Ah!
Ouch!
I didn't even feel like I...
Okay, let's eat.
Oh, wrong button.
Let's eat.
Calorie, mate.
I was gonna grab them.
Oh my gosh.
I had to leave.
I'm getting all the fish.
Did they...
Oh, no!
Sending
my own thing back at me.
Wait, how'd you see me?
Oh my gosh, wait.
Ah, you jerk.
Oh, oopsie.
What's he doing?
What are you delivering to me?
No, don't be mean like that.
Don't say I'm embarrassing myself.
You're not supposed to flashbang us.
Ah, no!
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
That's it?
Wait, seriously?
He took, like, three hits.
That's it.
Why was he so easy?
Oh, wait.
Oh, we're on phase two.
I was like, no way.
Wait.
God?
Okay, sometimes the dive takes, like, a bit to, uh...
To...
Get ready, you know?
No way!
How did you see me?
Is it the crock hat?
Is it my big old snout?
Is it my big snout?
Oh, my bad.
I'm sorry I tried to...
No, no, no, no, no.
Did I get him?
I think I did.
Dive, please.
Dive, dive, dive, dive!
My big snout's sticking out.
That's so funny.
Ah, shoot.
I think I missed.
Oops.
Smell the flying fish are crazy.
They're so funny.
Oh no!
No, no, no, no, no, no, dive, dive, dive, dive, dive, dive, dive, dive, dive, dive, please!
Oh my god!
Holy hell!
It is very, very annoying to do that.
sometimes oh my gosh it like the prompt is it's very slow ah bullet bee eating away at the inside of my body um what am i supposed to do with that do i carve him out oh i got him out yeah we just have a bullet bee that's eating away at my brain you know no no biggie um
Oh, they're bringing it back to me.
Okay.
Whatever.
Ah!
I suck at this guy.
There we go.
Oh, come on.
Then we got him a couple times.
That's bad.
No, I have to go down.
Wait, how'd you save me?
Is it my giant crocodile head?
And also, I hate that when I go underwater, it unequips everything.
Wait, why are you doing that?
It's very annoying.
Oh, this is good.
Okay, one more hit!
I'm leaving.
I like how you're saying smoke grenades when like, this is also working.
This is also working.
No!
But you're not covered!
Oh my gosh, dive, dive, dive.
The beat armor?
He wasn't covered that much.
Oh shh, now he is.
Like the pilot tricks.
Oh shoot.
Get him!
Oh,
shoot.
Got him before he could get me.
Pain relief.
See his victory against the pain.
The pain.
The pain!
Explode!
Oh my gosh.
It made my controller fall off.
The bird.
How do I get up there?
I've been told before that they explode because they don't want their bodies being taken and used for or like experiments I don't know wow we have a lot of vampire bats
that's damn good Sagan tells you that info
I thought it was so they can't get captured
I'm sure it's probably like a thing, though.
If they're captured and they're tested upon, they just blow up.
But also, I know there's a Kero-Tan.
We saw him.
I wonder if we can still get him from here.
Yes.
Oh gosh.
How high do I need to aim for him?
Higher?
I only have nine bullets left.
Let's do a different gun.
I didn't even realize how...
Whoops.
How low I was.
I don't know why I do that every time.
Sorry, guys.
Meem.
For you?
Let's try.
Oh, my shotgun.
Where is it?
pick up that one, right?
Wait, where's the one that I picked up under the bridge?
Did I die before I...
Where is he?
There he is.
Easy.
I don't need no shotgun.
Wrong gun.
Doesn't matter.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
it was a virtuous mission and we lose everything.
You guys are so right.
There we go.
Yeah!
Wait, what does that do?
Wearing it removes any handshake when readying weapons for Atlas was for us a lot.
Boards off hornets, spiders, and leeches.
Also allows wearer to tame hornets?
Hot dog.
where i guess the hornet's nests what
i'm a beekeeper
yeah we'll see what sagan says about this
the weapon you've got equipped now is a prototype model of the mark 22 a suppressor equipped i'm gonna get my food development by the Navy.
It's been modified to act as a tranquilizer gun.
The Mark 22 is a heavily modified special ops version of the M39 pistol used as a sidearm by the seals.
Probably the biggest change from the M39 is that it's got a longer barrel, which allows it to be equipped with a suppressor.
And it uses a slide lock mechanism.
That makes it a lot quieter, but it also means you have to load a new round into the chamber by hand every time you fire.
It's also fitted with you can use the front and rear sights to line up your shot even with a suppressor attached looks like they got rid of the magazine safety too good eye that feature wasn't too popular with guys like you who know their guns the sheer release lever has been taken off as well meaning the hammer won't fall even with the safety on so I can just cock and lock that and you get the added bonus of not having any mechanical noise from decocking even with the safety on the Perfect pistol for a sneaking mission,
huh?
Why are you guys blushing?
What did I miss?
A cap shake like a crocodile head, you say?
Yeah, what do you think?
I think it's a great idea.
You know, animal disguises are one of the oldest tricks in the book in the intelligence world.
I don't know whether it's true or not, but I've heard that during World War II, SS used to use cow suits supposedly they sent agents out to hide in herds of real cows so they could spy on enemy units as they passed by I will hold this again nowadays I guess most people wouldn't even give a crocodile shaped cap a second look 24 they think it was just a gag item but if you use it the right way it can be an effective weapon for spying I got a head to you snake you're one sharp guy you okay snake now forget it huh He just wants to make everybody laugh.
Snake, what's that camouflage?
It's called Hornet Stripe.
I got it from the pain.
No kidding.
Sounds like a pretty unique design.
From the looks of it, it's somehow infused with the power of Hornets.
The power of Hornets?
Sure.
When you're wearing that outfit, Hornets won't attack you.
Neither will spiders or leeches.
Crazy.
You might even be able to tame the ones that come flying out of a hive.
How do you do that?
How do you tame them?
It's crazy.
I see you've got yourself a ration.
Rations are portable meals carried by Soviet soldiers.
No, they're not.
They're disgusting portable meals carried by Soviet soldiers.
Hey, you should be grateful.
Thank you.
And they're surprisingly good for you too.
It is a lot of fun.
You should play it too.
Even if it's a little rotten.
You are hopeless.
Okay.
I got a little bit more food in my system.
Onwards.
What sucks is getting the...
The... what's it called?
the camel from the end and then for the rest of oh my god for the rest of the game it's like dark so you can't even really use it oh my gosh you know what's gonna come in handy here a big old craw cat
oh yamoko moboko
demon demon
I'm gonna grab another...
No.
I forgot I have limited ammo.
Ah, that's okay.
What we're gonna do...
I guess I could stun them.
I'll stun them.
Let's change into...
You?
Oh, it didn't work.
Oh wait, I think they still die, don't they?
Oops.
Well, the poison frogs are fine because we can give those to the soldiers and they'll eat it.
And get sick.
My eyes!
Sorry.
I turned around, to be fair.
I did turn.
I didn't look it in the eyes this time.
Oh.
I remember this cave.
I remember here.
Ammoful.
That's what we need.
You turn the camera, not snake.
Ah, that's how it works!
Ah!
Oh, let's recharge our batteries.
Hey.
Oh, my food is full.
What can we eat?
Let's get rid of some vampire badge.
We don't need this.
Food history.
Oh, wow.
That's kind of fun.
select dispense there we go false Russian false mango if you're hungry get some food may I offer you a rat I
love the effect it's so cool don't fall all right Back to the Russian jungle.
If I, do I fall and die there?
Do you want to save?
Mm-hmm.
Snake, have you seen 007 from Russia with Love?
Why do you think I'm saving?
Nah, I don't like those movies.
Real spies are nothing like James Bond.
It's pure fantasy.
Snake, I don't think the major's going to like you saying that.
And even though it's fiction, I can't help but comparing myself to Bond.
you like about james bond i mean is it the fantastic gadgets the cars the guns major snake wouldn't you like to have a gun shaped like a pen what good is a pen gonna do me in the jungle i'd look like a fool then what about a snake-shaped gun you can make it look like you're grappling with a giant snake and then get a shot in on the enemy while they're distracted okay now you're being ridiculous we'll make you a snake-shaped gun that folds up and fits into an attache case the way you're worried about how to handle the ladies aren't you no i knew it particularly the truth i don't like the idea of playing hanky panky with enemy fem fatals either but that's part of bond's appeal you could learn a thing or two from him i mean what about this evo what are you planning to do with her i i don't even trust her yet no that's not what i mean you you can't let yourself get involved this is a game of spy versus spy she's using you just as much as you're using her I realize that yeah have a little
fun the initiative and to do that you have to get the upper hand no strings attached that's what a spy is supposed to do get the upper hand I don't think I'm cut out for that mission maybe if you change your code name to double o snake double o seven is the biggest thing to come out of England since the Mayflower I wouldn't be surprised if they made 20 more of those movies didn't you know The major is a huge James Bond fan.
Don't get him worked up like this.
Worked up.
Maybe you don't realize this, but now that you've got him started talking about Bond, I'm going to have to listen to him lecture for a whole hour after he gets off the radio.
Snake, after fighting a man who patrols bees, 007 is unrealistic.
It's too bad you can't enjoy such a great movie, though.
Right.
I guess I'm just one of those people who can't enjoy Spyflex.
I love that one, too.
Wait.
I know what we need to wear.
Major Zero single-handedly funded the franchise until he's dying.
You think they'll notice?
I'm gonna test it.
This is for science.
I'm just gonna walk on through.
For science!
Uh, I'm scared.
Where am I?
Keep crouching.
For science?
Oh, for science!
It worked!
Wait, what are those birds?
See them birds?
I don't know how far over this guy comes.
Oh, okay, he stops.
I know I can just swim.
I'll just swim.
Oh, that's not swimming.
Oh, what a thrill.
Nope, that's not swimming.
thought we were going to kick off for real that time.
I thought it was Zunzo for us.
I'm searching for a crocodile.
I am crawling.
I think the water won't allow me for some reason.
There we go.
Chaff grenades.
Take those for sure.
Oh, what a thrill.
Just a crack.
Wow, it's really cool seeing the game.
Like, oh, whoops, I didn't mean to swim again.
Seeing everything, like, I could see underwater.
It's kind of insane.
There's something weird about that human-shaped crocodile.
I think we might need to kill people here.
Do you have any friends?
Because if so, everybody's sleeping with the fishes tonight.
There's your friend.
Oh, I forgot I got more.
I was like, wait, I can't waste my bullets.
No, no.
Oh!
It's so satisfying watching them go down now.
Oh, oh no no no.
Upsies, upies, upies, upies, snake, upies.
Snake asks for upies, there we go.
Everybody's living with the fishes, but that's not me killing them.
Pick up.
Pick them up.
Hello?
Pick him up.
Snake.
What the hell are you doing, mister?
Pick him up.
Okay.
Oh, he's so gentle.
Oh, snake!
This is big old feet.
Oh my gosh.
I can't even take this.
Okay, I give up.
How do I get in there?
Is that all?
Oh, oh, yeah.
More chaff.
Let's go?
Skull faces.
We don't want to think about what that guy's doing.
We don't think about him.
Suppressor, yeah.
Suppressor.
Wait.
Was this a...
Okay.
Yes!
We gotta get this if we want to maybe kill somebody in the next scene.
Uh-oh, Hungy?
Ah, we can leave.
I wish I...
Wait, what is that?
I wish I could ever tell what anything is.
So I can know before I waste my time.
Okay.
You're too slow, Snake, when you're just...
Stop stomping around!
Okay, I don't know.
We're hungry.
I don't think I see anything over there.
Well, where are Gakko and Kero-Tan?
Actually, now I think about it.
Not so great.
Snake with the grippers.
Kero-Tan?
Gakko?
you've missed 260 kettle times maybe maybe I have no we haven't been through 260 areas shut up shut up actually does it say there's only 64 you've been to 259 areas oh I see when you go to a new area it automatically gives you that map prompt that's pretty nice actually luckily I know where we're going I
don't think he'll get catch shoot me over here and long nose croc is actually a species called a gareo and they are rarely a threat to large mammals yes I'm that guy.
Go to sleep as soon as stream starts.
Wake up for work.
Wonder how far Min got.
Seas are swimming around.
Dumbass cracks, dude.
Hell yeah.
Um.
Yeah, this is how we look.
Very cool.
But here's the real question.
We have a decision.
No.
Wait, I'm gonna say, okay, this is what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna save, I'm gonna try.
And then, I will reload.
I say do it because you never do.
But I also wanna see the new fight, you know?
You want to save?
Yes.
So that's what we'll do.
Snake, have you heard of the last war?
Nope, doesn't ring a bell.
It's a Japanese movie where the world ends a nuclear war tensions between east and west reach the breaking point and before anyone can stop it they launch the icbms humanity is wiped out by a war that no one wanted the movie depicts that destruction from the eyes of ordinary people their simple daily lives are torn apart by the terrible power of a war that has nothing to do with them everybody's afraid of the next big war but there's only so much i'm scared i've never sniped him before that's why the people
to sorry paramedic I was not paying attention to you I was snacking okay the crocodile body with the gun is kind of insane oh my gosh wait I hope someone pisses their pants
Tatiana I'm doing that right now.
Get your hands off me.
Seems like a fun time.
Really now?
How many times must I tell you?
Uh-huh.
My headphones just fell into my food.
Each time you resist, your lover will suffer the consequences.
Is that clear?
I think I'm okay.
I have a blanket.
Oh, not a blanket.
Oh, napkin.
We're fine.
Tatiana, are you okay, girl?
Damn you.
My chat froze on YouTube.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
Vulcan!
Aw.
Hold it right there, traitor.
Gosh, I...
I love this part.
Let's find out just how lucky you are.
Lucky guy.
The Muggler.
Watch closely.
Oh my god.
One of these three guns has a single bullet in it.
I'm going to pull the trigger six times in a row.
Are you ready?
This is so crazy.
Every game.
Looks like your luck hasn't run out yet.
This is so steamy.
No!
She's so cool.
There's no such thing as luck on the battlefield.
You're smart.
I love laughing with Vulcan.
You'd better stay in line from now on.
Come on.
That's a lot.
Keep it together.
Mom.
Oh, please.
The Cobras will take care of him.
And I have him again back my home, please.
Oh.
He looks so shocked.
He's like, this is why I don't deal with women.
Has the CIA dog been disposed of yet?
dead what he may
be a child but he's definitely one of yours he that she's a grown-ass man I'm sorry when a child
looks so good right I love the way Volgan looks it's so cool you must eliminate him before the final test don't worry they'll be able to handle it come on out grandpa this is how i felt like they were wheeling out some of the voice actors at the con
i'm leaving him to you with a fear
the old man is always sleeping is he all right the end is saving what life he has left in him for battle normally he's dead come on but it wake up i can make him deader
he's here and when he does it will be the end for the boy
patiana's just like do i need to stay here sokolov isn't worth your love You can entertain me until the rain stops.
Oh, Tatiana.
Oh.
What the?
The sorrow.
Is that you?
Uh.
How are you?
Oh, I saw him for two seconds.
I went the wrong way.
Do you see him for two seconds?
All right, here we go.
I'm not gonna miss.
I might miss.
Wait, where is he?
Wait.
Where'd he go?
Oh, how do I use this thing?
Oh, here we go.
Ah!
I miss!
Wait, hold on.
Let me reload chat real quick because you guys are frozen.
Yeah!
One second, one second, one second.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, let's reload.
I'll obviously skip through the cutscene.
Wait, did it auto save before or after?
I know, he becomes really fast.
Like here?
How, what's the...
What's, like, the angle?
So, let me turn it down.
Or, not angle, the...
You know, where I need to line up the sides.
A little too high.
Okay.
A little too high, a little too low.
Like here?
Ah!
Like, in my...
Wait, hold on.
Top of the triangle
Like here Got
it Seize victory against the end Kill the end before boss battle Yeah we did it We did it Hey
Okay Yeah nice I got I got two achievements for that So that's good
We'll wait for him to leave, though.
We'll wait for his little guy to...
Oh, oops.
Nope.
I'm a crocodile.
I'm a stand-in crock.
Oh!
No.
I'm sorry.
Oh, oops.
Wrong gun.
Absolutely not.
Roha's eagle eyes.
Ah, right!
Scrogg is pointing a gun at me.
As long as I don't...
I think as long as I don't...
Stand up, I'm okay.
Okay, there's two other guys.
Yeah, just a bug.
Fall into the water.
Dang.
Oh!
Yes!
Oh my god, best situation best outcome ever and
shoot good enough for me and shoot good enough for me yep just your imagination fall into the water oh my god he did
that's crazy all right go to sleepy time now mister I swear...
There it is.
Wackle, wackle.
Get out, get out.
Nicer!
Let's grab some stuff.
Stuff.
They're like a super poisonous...
Oh.
Is it these guys?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I want the spiders to like me.
What was it?
Spiders!
Befriend me.
Oh, it's the hornets only.
I don't know why I thought the spiders would befriend me.
Well, we got Kedotan.
Where is Gakko?
Oh, come in.
Come in.
Inside we go.
What else you got?
You know, I haven't tried getting any of the secret theater stuff.
Maybe we can hold up some guy at some point.
The warehouse.
Okay.
Whoa, it would be good camo here.
Are all...
Oh, tiger strut.
Gold is negative 130.
A box?
Oh my gosh, wait.
You're so right.
where's my box the cardboard box can I shoot actually since we haven't tried it yet I can see first person if I cannot shoot for a minute still too OP I suppose
just a box
oh I love being able to lay side by...
Oops.
Oopsie.
Just kidding.
My being.
I mean, they're little whoopsie.
I can't...
Oh gosh.
Why does it feel like the boxes are bigger in this?
I think I got them.
Yeah.
That sound is like you getting them.
Right?
Right.
Did he fall?
Okay, I think there's only two guys in here.
Though, I honestly can't remember.
Oh, definitely more than two guys.
Okay, just kidding.
Kero-tan.
He's, like, glowing.
Wait, where is the other guy?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my suppressor.
I forgot to put it in the next one.
I forgot to...
Easy.
See?
No problems here.
No problems here, everybody.
Nice shot, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Onwards.
Okay, so this is the one we have to fall.
Stealth 100?
Actually.
Okay.
Okay, and hang.
And...
And grab.
Thank you.
Definitely need that.
Onwards and upwards.
Oh, yeah, the good stuff.
I could blow this up, but...
It's fine.
Have the guys be real hungry and sad.
No?
His bag shakes when he's walking up the stairs.
Where are you staring, eh?
Greninja Gorky.
Oh, no.
Oh.
My monitor does not like it.
this place.
It's like flickering a little bit.
Can't remember if there's only boobies traps in here or if there's also men.
I think there's no men right now and then they become boobies or become men later.
I can't remember.
I have a, well, I guess I'm, let's see.
Hmm.
Only boobies.
Okay, yeah.
So only Nice.
And then, and then there will be men later.
Little frog.
I can't see anything.
I wish I could full screen.
I wish I could full screen my game.
I'm sure they're pretty obvious.
Like that.
Oh, wait.
We got ourselves a sexy book.
Yes, we do.
Wait, I want to see also the Dead people!
Yeah!
Dead guy.
Ew.
I don't think he should be swaying that much.
I don't think he should be moving that much for someone who's dead.
Leca pinata.
Oh, that's a snake.
This is a snake.
That is a booby trap.
no climb I haven't done this at all I've been like I've been pretty bad about sneaking honestly I feel I haven't been so great about like utilizing things but it is what it is whoa and I did see Kero-Tan I saw him I saw him right there oh hungry Let's go,
let go, let go, let go, let go, let go, let go, let go, let go, let go, let go, let's some ramen.
Oh my gosh, bunny!
It's so cute!
Stand tall, bunny.
Wow, he's not afraid of me at all.
Just kidding, there he goes.
I see a bunny and he get hungry, huh?
Let's have a false mango.
Ah.
Pretty tasty.
We got lots of ink.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
We got lots of ink caps in here.
I think I don't need to explore.
Okay, there's a trap right there.
This is a trap.
Watch out.
Watch your toes.
Okay.
I'm being extra cautious.
I was being extra cautious.
Why is suddenly Gakko so hard to find?
Wait.
I think those are boobokos.
I thought they were hornet's nests.
Wait.
I see.
I spy with my little eyes.
something yellow where is he I just saw him you guys saw him too right game looks so good it honestly it plays really well it's really fun like it's it's great I'm really happy like any complaints that I would have
Or, like, it doesn't even matter, I feel.
I'm having so much fun.
Where the hell is this guy?
I saw him!
Maybe from...
A ribbit?
Wait, can I...
This is just making noise, right?
Ah.
Oh well.
I could see him from here.
Hold on.
Oh, there he is.
See?
See, Gakko right there.
Maybe I can get him with my...
Yubi!
Okay, we got both for this area.
Ah!
I'm
an alligator here.
It'll work.
Oh, I forgot about the dogs here.
That was some pretty fancy shooting.
You're pretty good.
It really does sound like hot dog.
Hot dog, hot dog, hot dog.
What did the animal one give me again?
Oh, wait, no, I don't remember.
Oh, handshake.
Sorry, I thought my cat snuck in here.
Let's see.
A little change, though.
Naked!
Naked woodland is...
Plus 30?
No way!
They just want me to be naked.
Oh, I have the woodland on.
I want to see my body.
For science.
Where are...
Where...
Oh, wait.
See, there's a scratch there.
I want to get beat up without dying.
And see what...
Oh, there's a scratch on my arm?
I want to get beat the hell up.
Punch me.
Punch me right now.
Look at his hair.
It's so fluffy.
Oh my gosh, look at his hair.
A scar on his face, too.
Spin him.
You're right.
It's time.
It's time to spin our baby boy.
Oh.
Go, Rambo, go.
Spin.
It's time.
Ralph called.
Make Snake throw up.
It's an achievement.
Oh, come on.
They want you to make him throw up.
Yeah, you're stupid.
What if he fell onto the...
Oh!
No, no, dog.
Stop moving so fast.
Dog, stop moving.
Dog.
Wait.
The dog's down?
Yes.
Oh, where are I going to get you from?
There.
There we go.
Okie dokie.
We'll crawl in over here.
Dog is down.
One moment, hold on.
I'm being secret.
Is this the one with the hole over here?
Yes.
Granini Gorky Lab exterior.
Oh, that's a guy like right next to me.
I can't see.
The grass is too thick.
I get him though.
Those friend notice.
What's wrong?
Hello?
I don't know.
The way they say it in this game is so funny.
Oh, I'm hungry.
Reticulated python.
Nice shot, thank you.
That's tasty.
I can't stop quoting snake whenever I eat something good now.
The way that this series has absolutely, like, completely altered my brain chemistry is kind of scary.
It's kind of scary how much I'm, like...
always quoting stuff now and just like I I can't stop I legitimately just have become a become broke brain from this from the series twas
fate I should have thrown him a frog I think I got him though
what was back here
More stuff.
Oh.
Which way do I want to go?
I think, actually, Kero-Tan is...
If they kept Kero-Tan in the same place...
Okay, I do know that there's also...
The storage over there.
Yes, Kero-Tan is still in the same place.
What's this?
XM...
16E1.
Fancy.
Giving me a whole lot of stuff for me and my no-kill run.
I guess we'll just go in through the front door.
Akero time's there, but how...
Also, how...
Where Gakko and also how get...
Can I shoot through the window?
I don't remember how.
Yep.
Thank you.
And we put on our suit.
Time to become a scientist.
Oh!
Wait, double glasses.
Never mind.
Wait, bigger, nerdier glasses.
Which one?
Okay, which one do you guys think are the nerdier glasses?
These glasses or these glasses?
Which one are the nerdier glasses?
One or two?
No kill run, Minto, you just electrocuted.
I didn't electrocute him, he shouldn't have fallen onto the fence!
Two?
Since they are new, we'll try those.
We'll try the new ones.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
Wiggle, wiggle.
I'm in Grenini Gorky.
And I am a scientist.
I am a scientist.
I...
Okay, this is for science.
If I run...
Okay, they don't care.
If I go in there, I might get caught.
Just don't touch them.
Don't act suspicious.
If I crouch...
He doesn't care.
That guy looks like Otakon for real.
I heard Keto Tan go on Marko Wiggle.
I want to see the sexy lady over here.
Oh, I see her.
You see her?
These guys are...
Oh, that's...
Ah, hey, hey.
It's so funny.
The scientists have, like, 2020 vision crazy.
Like, they'll see you walking by and they'll be like, Um, who that?
Um, I don't recognize that guy.
It's so annoying.
They kept it.
I missed.
I missed just a bit.
One more try.
There we go.
I heard the sound.
I heard it.
Oh my gosh, she looks so serious.
There's nothing, not that much in the background.
Whoa.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
I can't wait to play this game again and just do photo mode everywhere.
I can't wait to do so much photo mode.
Yay!
um where am i oh here we go this leads to outdoors i remember but this guy can see me from inside and be like i'm who not it's downstairs i need to go to no oops wrong one photo playthrough maybe that can be like a members thing this is a photo playthrough me just playing whenever i want and getting all sorts of silly goofy
pictures in every place.
Is anybody in here?
Nice.
Getting lots of suppressors all of a sudden.
It's awesome.
Okay, I'm trapped.
Are there ghost photos?
No, there are no ghost photos in MGS3.
Unfortunately.
What's here?
Honestly, the balcony?
Yeah.
Oh.
I didn't mean to go through.
Well, we got our chocolate chip!
Wait, that's a fun...
That's a fun codec call, too.
Ghost bottom, right?
Any of the ladies in here?
I'm not gonna think I'm weird for going inside, are there?
Can't see?
Dr. Bandana.
Oh, we have a beautiful picturesque painting.
Oh, hello.
Are you coming over here or?
I'm doing, I'm conducting very legitimate science.
Hello?
Okay.
I'm doing research on...
Okay, my goodness!
Oh, that's the thing that is alive.
Instant noodles.
I don't want to...
We'll eat the red.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Indeed.
Alright.
What's in here?
Oh.
Body.
Hello?
I guess this is a few, you know, is there people who are not
who are not going to play with the scientist outfit?
And we'll...
Oh, there's spiders in the wall in here!
Nasty!
Um, is there anything over here?
Excuse me, can I sleep?
Sneak past you?
There you go.
Okay.
What's in here?
Oh, storage.
Oh, nice.
Yes, I remember this.
Okay.
I think there's something.
Nope.
I thought there was something on top.
No, I'm thinking of another building.
What's here?
Dirty book.
Someone's, uh...
Someone's stash.
Alright, cool.
Now we can go downstairs.
I heard!
I heard Gakko.
I heard.
Hi, Dad.
I heard it.
Also, my room is now so much cooler in case anyone's wondering.
How long am I even streaming?
Almost seven hours.
Why am I?
I hear him.
Like, it's trying to...
What do you think you're doing?
Sorry.
I'm running.
You can hear that they give you hints.
It's kind of funny.
It doesn't feel like seven hours, though.
It feels...
It feels way less.
I hear him.
Giving me hints.
Ew, there's spiders on the...
Ouch!
Are you kidding me?
As soon as I said something?
I hate this.
I'm suffering from venom poison.
This is me when I play.
I'm suffering for venom poisoning.
No!
Don't touch me.
I'm a doctor and I love to role play.
I'm in jail.
Is there anything under there?
Oh.
Is that the way we need to crawl?
Hello.
Watch out for those spies.
If I were a mouse...
I would get caught in your trap any day, Miss Haruna Yabuki.
Oh!
Sorry.
You don't notice anything.
I didn't mean to press that.
I got really excited about her.
Oh.
Yeah?
Oh, no.
He looks really stupid.
I did the horny front flip.
Should I change and then seek you see him?
I think so.
Oh shit, he healed.
Miss Yabuki, save me!
We're fine.
They have no idea.
What's wrong?
Oh, gosh, they're going to hear my tummy.
I love caution music.
I actually don't remember how I'm supposed to get over there.
long timer oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I don't remember Karina Yabuki has 20k followers on Instagram you looked her up so bad you were like you you saw a prize and he went for it we did get a lot of good nutritional things but I don't let my tummy get down a little bit further.
I'm glad that they are still too stupid to look under the bed.
Prize on the eyes, me too.
So true, mig.
He's moonwalking.
Guys, I can't remember how to get it over to I almost said AIMS again.
Oh my gosh.
Because he says, you must be Sokolov.
I always want to say, you must be AIMS.
I want to say that all the time.
You must be AIMS.
Nah.
One of the other models later.
He has a hundred K followers?
Holy cow.
I'm eating some rice.
I heated up earlier.
Okay.
Rice and chicken.
Yes, yes.
You ever giggle to yourself when you say a Kojima trigger word and we all say the thing?
I don't giggle to myself.
I giggle out loud.
I love when you guys enable me.
Guys, I don't remember
Guys, I don't remember how to get to Sokolov.
I can't remember.
The nerd lab.
Hello, I'm the scientist that you saw earlier and thought nothing strange about.
Wait, is the guy still in there?
Or did he come out?
Sorry, I'm so hungry.
They don't feed us here.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, cute!
Wow, they kept those.
Oh!
Run.
Ah!
This is so unfair.
This is so unfair!
I'm an innocent little scientist!
No!
Oh, I just...
Got through caution, please!
No!
Are you gonna look?
I'm gonna throw a snake at you.
Uh...
Where was my snake?
Oh wait, we can throw a frog.
Throw a frog sea at them.
Did you hear that noise?
Yeah!
Ah.
Nothing here.
I'm gonna throw frogs so you have them again.
Wait, where'd it go?
Oh, it's not in my inventory anymore, huh?
Gotta put it back on my backpack.
Poison dart frog!
No!
Did you hear that noise?
Eat up!
Oh, I'm so annoyed.
I don't want to wait all the way for caution.
I almost want to restart.
Wait, if I load...
Oh, I didn't...
Ugh.
Never mind.
Nothing here.
Please leave.
I got... I was... I didn't... I didn't see him!
I was doing so well, kind of, well, you know, I didn't...
Ah, okay, I'm bleeding.
Oof.
Snake, are you okay?
I could kill.
You think they'll know...
They will know it's me if I...
If I...
Leave now, but even in with this...
What is it?
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm trying to remember.
How to get to Sokolov.
And my brain is not coming up with it.
Okay, Shreig.
I'm sorry.
I'm starving you.
There you go.
Mmm.
I'm going to save.
You want to save?
Yeah.
Hold on a sec.
Snake, have you seen Earth versus the spider?
Do you think he has?
It's about the spider that suddenly mutates into a giant monster.
Oh.
They bring it into the city in a state of hibernation, but it wakes up and starts wrecking the place.
So why did the spider turn huge?
I told you, it suddenly mutated.
Yeah, right.
Snake, it's people like you that take all the fun out of watching movies.
Always nitpicking and taking things too seriously.
Honestly, why even bother?
Look, the important thing isn't that it got big.
Then what is important?
The fact that there's a huge spider destroying the city.
Suspend your disbelief.
That's the whole point of movies.
Exactly.
paramedic you could you could not piss me off you could reassure me that everything's okay not piss me off okay
the second silliest man is too serious okay we only have 16 15 seconds left and then I They won't run into any more soldiers.
I pinky promise.
Break your promise, break your pinky.
I'll break every single one of yours.
Two!
One!
Didi!
Cancelling the alert.
Return to your position.
Oh wait, what's over here?
Okay.
Have they left?
Is it safe to open the door?
You don't see me.
Gornini Gorky.
Me?
Hello, sir.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to get around this box.
What was this room?
Oh, here we go.
Ah.
Hello.
Ah, ha, ha, ha.
It's a nini-minkey.
Oh, he did it.
Oh, that's right.
Here we go.
Here's where we go through the nerd lab.
Oh, don't mind me.
I want to get in here, too, though.
There's a...
Isn't there, like, another gun in here?
here if I remember correctly there was oh wait I think it's actually the sig the isn't the cigarette spray I think actually hello don't walk into me I'll walk around you oh I'm trying please I'm trying not to do that I don't want to seem so suspicious.
Yes!
Ah!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
I knew it.
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
I'm sorry, sir.
Uh, I don't mean to run into you.
He looked right at the camera.
Oh, my gosh.
We did it.
Wait, I need to get over there, mister.
Can you move?
Don't notice me.
Oh no.
Wait, I'm scared.
I'm scared of this room.
This is my...
Oh, Gakko.
Of course there would be a battery in here.
I'm just gonna run for it.
Oh my!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, it's time for our shoes!
Wait, this one is great!
Oh my gosh, we're...
We're scientists the whole time.
Wait, now are the figures behind him?
Are they, like, really high-deaf?
If you're looking for Sokolov, he's not here anymore.
Wow, it's the old theme.
Spoil my drink.
So, you're the intruder everyone's talking about.
Typical capitalist dog.
It is so high-deaf.
manners hey and who are you you mean you've never heard of me the guy on the wall oh my gosh wait everything is so high-deaf this is insane you guys are kind of blocking go to the enders i am alexander leonovich granin a man of some importance if i do say so myself oh my god i am the foremost weapon scientist in the soviet union I'm the head of the glorious Grunian design bureau literal jump scare this is the order of Lenin it is an honor of the greatest magnitude given along with the title of hero of socialism to only the finest workers it was awarded to me in recognition of my brilliant contributions to society since the great patriotic war I have created countless weapons in the service of our great communist society.
Oh, there's Ray on the right.
It was thanks to me that we were able to stamp out the Nazi scum.
It was I who created the basic design for the mobile ballistic missile system you know and fear as SS-1C.
Oh, is this rematch?
You're crocked, aren't you?
It's not me.
I'm merely drowning in my sorrow.
Actually, not me this time.
Because of him.
I've got nothing to do but sit here.
Drink this crap.
Him.
Sokolov.
It's him you're looking for, isn't it?
Uh-huh.
I have been stripped of my authority.
My research has come to nothing.
It's kind of crazy.
Look Like Granon's the guy that came up with stuff.
It is a revolutionary mobile nuclear missile system a bipedal tank Oh my god, it's so high depth a bipedal tank Yes, a walking tank a robot It's crazy.
Are you familiar with the theory?
It's so crazy It's crazy.
Between apes and humans.
And then someone comes in and steals it all.
This technology will be the missing link between infantry and artillery.
It's actually, it tries to be insane.
And this magnificent metal gear will mark a revolutionary step forward in weapons development.
Metal gear.
But I won't be used so easily.
No, no crying myself to sleep.
Oh, you see, I'm going to send these documents to my friend in the United States.
Ah!
This bastard will live to regret this.
Oh my god!
And when they themselves become the targets of my creation, they will know my true greatness.
Yes.
Sokolov's pathetic shagohan pales in comparison to my work.
Don't do it!
For real!
What are you going to do with a rocket engine on a tank?
Don't do it, Granin!
How about Sokolov?
The tank does not need a rocket.
It needs something else.
Look at these.
Nice shoes.
No.
Legs.
Legs that allow it to go anywhere.
Just as when humans learn to walk up.
That is the real revolution in weaponry.
Don't you agree?
He's actually so dumb.
But, the fool's in charge.
it's your sokolov and where is sokolov my project has been terminated philosopher's legacy has been handed over to him what the hell are you talking about the philosopher's legacy oh my gosh you guys I have that right here on my desk you think I'm at the target now their immense legacy we'll get The music is so whimsical,
it's funny.
Volgin's money laundering activities.
In the confusion of the war, they somehow ended up with their treasure.
And Volgin inherited that treasure illegally.
We never need to worry about the military budget.
The development costs at our facility are all paid out of the colonel's deep pockets.
The weapons born here will be the genes for creating an entirely new form of warfare because I have the philosopher's legacy the funding for my research came out of that legacy came out of it now my money my men all have been diverted to the Shagohan project tomorrow they will be conducting the final test while Sokolov is making the final preparations in the weapons factory at Volgan's main base the great fortress of Grozny Grad.
Here I am, playing host to an enemy spy and drinking myself into a stupor.
That's where they move Sokolov.
Yes.
And the Shagohod is there, too.
Of course.
Hey, you're not thinking of going to Grozny Grad.
Are you mad?
It's an impenetrable fortress.
I'm sure it is.
You'll be killed.
I'll take my chances.
at so high-deaf wait what listen to me i want to help you help me oh oh sorry oh my god what compliment i just did wait how do you how did i do that no tachiana gave them to me i wanted to thank you for complimenting me on me i'll tell you how to get into the fortress in return i ask only that idiot out of there and destroy the Shagohan.
It's not.
Oh, oh, God.
There is an underground tunnel that runs around the perimeter.
Oh, my God.
You should be able to use it to sneak into the base.
No, it's L2.
Sorry, I'm stupid.
I can't.
I mixed up my left and my right.
The entrance to the tunnel is located there.
Take this.
What's that?
Enhance.
you passed through a warehouse on your way here didn't you yes yeah there should have been a locked door inside of it will you remember it no this key uh-huh open that door okay beyond that door lies a vast jungle you can climb up into the mountains from the far end of the jungle Go back to the warehouse.
That door.
Use the key to open the locked door.
Camera's been drinking too.
Sorry.
I don't want to make anybody feel sick.
Why are you helping me?
Unlike Sokolov, the thought of defecting has never once crossed my mind.
I love my country.
I love this land.
I cannot even imagine living anywhere else.
I wish I could have known about the Zoom when put the shoes.
I cannot bear the thought of being hounded into a corner and left to waste away.
It is already dark.
Oh gosh.
We must hurry.
I will remain here and nurse my troubles for a little longer.
It even like, you see that?
It, like, blurs the background.
To capitalism.
It's kind of crazy.
Maybe something you could use in the theater later.
Right!
To capitalism.
Ha.
Well, guys, it's only been seven hours, but I think I'm going to call it here.
Um...
Hold on, let me see my calendar for this week.
Because I haven't put out a schedule yet.
I think I'll pick up...
Oh, wait, I was going to finish...
I was going to try and do Walking Dead twice.
Maybe I'll just do it next week.
I'm not streaming tomorrow.
No, no, no.
I will put out a schedule.
I might move some stuff around.
Since now I'm currently doing three games, Half-Life, Walking Dead, and Metal Gear, so...
I do want to try and get this done, though, so I might start at the same time on Sunday and just kind of power through it.
I would do Saturday as a Metal Gear Saturday thing, but I have a collab that day.
yeah i think we'll do that what do you guys think so far oh my gosh it like i said i think earlier like it's the same experience but also feels so different at the same time things are this super fun stream and this has been fun and you should play with what you want whatever you want thank you dorko thank you for the peek yeah like it plays very smoothly it's i you know I I know a lot of people were cautiously optimistic and a lot of people were very skeptical but I think they knocked it out of the park I would like to I think I could say that I think it's I think it's been good so yeah yeah yeah yeah my first time watching someone play Metal Gear,
it looks super fine.
Yes!
This is the first game in the timeline.
So, um, you know, a good place to start if you want to.
Um, but I'm, I'm, I'm, I am so happy.
I should be using some of, I feel like I've used the Croc outfit most of the time, but, oh, whoops.
Well, I feel like I should use some of the other DLC outfits that I got.
Like, grenade I use a lot, because why would I?
Happy to catch the stream today, Minto.
Thank you!
I don't play much Metal Gear and know much about it.
But whenever I see it, I always get enjoyment out of it.
Just got back from AMIC.
Had a blast.
Can't help feeling some MGS con foe, but...
MGS con?
con phoma i feel like amic was so much fun too i wouldn't have known which one to pick either miss thank you so much for the peek yeah i think i'm just all i mean i'm usually metal gear brand but right now i'm like i'm i'm deep deep in it i'm i'm i'm because my love was really revived by the con like it was just you know there's like obviously going to an anime convention is a lot of fun but yeah yeah thanks jordan princess but going to something that is like a specialized niche like a like a singular fandom kind of convention is so so different because everybody is on like the same wavelength everybody's telling the same jokes everybody's kind of vibing with the same stuff like anybody you could turn to your left you could turn to your right anybody next to you could become a potential friend because you already have a uh a similar interest you know everyone has the same brain rod exactly it's really nice and a bit for me of not having seen much overplayed mgs3 to enjoy this without
any prejudgment thanks again and so happy to see you please thank you
I'm playing on PC can I wait actually I don't know any of the controls how do I save hold on wait okay hold on I'm gonna save I'm gonna save and then I'm gonna do some stuff like we're gonna mess around with it in the game snake in what's it called snake have you ever seen on the beach no I don't know it it's about the survivors of the Third World War.
And with, like, mouse and stuff.
I'm just gonna run in and blast it.
Nuclear holocaust.
And it's only a matter of time before the few survivors left in the Southern Hemisphere are poisoned by the deadly fallout.
Love you starting another Metal Gear.
Take care.
Thank you, Mauricio.
Thank you.
He set out for the Arctic to investigate the fallout.
Thank you so much.
The movie came out in 59 and the year that the war was supposed to happen was 1964.
Wait, what are that?
In other words, this year.
Nice woman.
the beach that's trending yeah on the beach mention okay oh i need to turn up the sensitivity like crazy first of all okay how do i okay what's my okay this is run i don't know okay all right e okay i'm going in blasting and this is okay
view okay I'm going in blasting oh I need to reload he left oh no we didn't I need I can't get up.
Wait, I don't know how to get up.
Wait.
Stand up, Snake!
Snake!
Oh, no, Snake!
I don't know how to stand up!
Wait!
Wait, please!
Space?
No, it doesn't let me.
I'm still going?
What's happening?
What's all the explosions for?
See?
Thank you.
Wait, see?
Wait, where'd he go?
Will they fade?
Wait, I think I would be so good at this game if I just...
Have I played on...
With mouse and keyboard!
I see you!
We almost missed Rion Kadena.
Um, everybody's dead.
Thank you everybody!
Otsubito!